[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat cette semaine la
commission d' enquête sur la sphère
benalla reprend ses travaux mercredi
matin à l'entendre à trois personnalités
proches de l'enquète françois-xavier
lauch chef de cabinet d' emmanuel macron
puis le général eric bio-farina
commandant militaire de la présidence de
la république et enfin maxence creusa
commissaire de police à la direction de
l'ordre public et de la circulation de
la préfecture de police de paris
c'est dans ce contexte que je vous
propose de revoir ce matin les temps
forts des auditions menées par la
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale qui
s'est constituée au mois de juillet à la
suite de l'affairé benalla sous l'égide
du président de la commission des lois
le sénateur à l'est républicain philippe
bas
les sénateurs ont auditionné de
nombreuses personnalités du ministre de
l'intérieur gérard collomb au secrétaire
général de l'elysée alexis kohler en
passant par le préfet de police de paris
michel delpech et les directeurs
généraux de la gendarmerie ou encore de
la police nationale ces auditions ont
été menées dans le calme et avec
pugnacité par les sénateurs ce qui a
permis de mettre en lumière un certain
nombre de contradictions
retour donc à ces auditions du mois de
juillet mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je me contenterai de quelques
mots introductifs très bref tout d'abord
je tiens à
à commencer par souscrire pleinement vos
réponses qui vous ont été apportées hier
par le directeur de cabinet du président
de la république patrick strzoda qui
comme vous le savez tous et un préfet de
très grande expérience dans le sens de
l'étape est reconnu par tous et qui a
toute ma confiance
j'ajoute que je considère que c'est une
grande chance pour moi comme secrétaire
général de présence de la république de
pouvoir compter sur son concours
quotidien
comme vous l'a également indiqué patrick
strzoda
le président de la république a autorisé
certains de ses collaborateurs à venir
devant vous afin de contribuer à la
manifestation de la vérité
il m'a néanmoins demandé de rappeler le
cadre juridique dans lequel s'inscrit
cette audition
je me semble en particulier déterminant
de souligner vous avez fait on à
monsieur le président l'importance du
respect de la séparation des pouvoirs
auxquels nous sommes tous attachés qui
me permettra pas de répondre aux
questions portant sur les faits donnant
lieu à des poursuites judiciaires ou à
celle portant sur l'organisation interne
de la présidence de la république
j'en viens à présent à l'objet même de
votre commission et aux événements du
1er mai j'ai passé l'après-midi du 1er
mai dernier à mon bureau le directeur de
cabinet m'a tenu informé du déroulement
des manifestations et des opérations de
maintien de l'ordre
je rappelle que ces manifestations se
sont révélés d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle au regard des violences
commises des commerces saccagés des
dégradations constatées et d un perte
interpellations auxquelles les forces de
l'ordre ont procédé
je veux saisir cette occasion pour
saluer l'engagement sans faille des
forces de l'ordre et le
professionnalisme dont elles ont fait
preuve au cours de ces événements la
question des événements de la place de
la contrescarpe now n'a à aucun moment
été mentionné
j'ai été informé le lendemain le 2 mai
dans la matinée par le conseiller en
charge notamment des réseaux sociaux et
le directeur de cabinet de la
publication sous les réseaux sociaux
d'une vidéo dans laquelle un individu
qui sa part s apparenter à monsieur
benalla se livrer à des actes
inappropriés et choquants dans le cadre
des opérations de maintien de l'ordre
sur la place de la contrescarpe à ce
moment le directeur de cabinet mme
indique qu'il a d'ores et déjà convoqué
l'intéressé qui a reconnu sa présence
sur les lieux et sa participation des
interprétations je m'assure que le
directeur de cabinet a bien vérifié
auprès de la préfecture de police et du
cabinet du ministre de l'intérieur de la
réalité des faits est retracée dans la
vidéo et qu'ils sont bien la forme nous
refaisons le point en fin de journée
constatant que les faits sont bien
avérée le directeur de cabinet m'informe
de son intention d'appliquer une
sanction disciplinaire sans délai ce qui
me semble totalement approprié nous nous
reparlons le lendemain et le directeur
de cabinet ma forme de la sanction
qu'ils entendent notifié à l'agent et
qu'il vous a parlé hier la suspension de
quinze jours avec votre salaire la
modification des responsabilités
confiées à l'intéressé la notification
portée au dossier
l'indication que tout nouveau
comportement fautif entraînerait un
licenciement qu'ils aient lieu par la
suite
compte tenu des éléments portés à notre
connaissance à ce moment là la sanction
apparaît proportionnée
au bout du compte la sanction a été
décidée dès le jour de la découverte des
faits est notifiée à l'intéressé
dès le lendemain j'ajoute un point
compte tenu de l'audition du directeur
de cabinet patrick strzoda hier devant
vous et devant les députés de celle du
commandant militaire du palais de
l'élysée général bio farina et du chef
du gspr le colonel lavergne
je pense j'espère que vous avez été
rassuré sur le fait qu'il n'existe pas à
l'elysée de police parallèle que nous
n'employons pas de vigiles privés pour
protéger le chef de l'état et que
monsieur benalla n'a jamais été en
charge de la protection du président de
la république je vous remercie et su à
votre disposition pour répondre à
l'ensemble de vos questions monsieur
benalla se voit infliger une sanction
mais il n'est pas mis fin à ses
fonctions
il n'est pas décidé de saisir la justice
est ce que vous aviez conscience le 2
mai ou es ce que vous avez pris
conscience depuis lors des risques que
faisait courir au président de la
république le maintien d'une telle
collaboration avec un agent qui s'était
ainsi comporter est ce que vous avez eu
conscience à ce moment là où pris
conscience depuis de la gravité du
trouble apporter au fonctionnement de
l'état par l'intrusion d'un
collaborateur du président de la
république dans une opération de
maintien de l'ordre à laquelle il a
participé
et est ce que vous avez pris conscience
de ce fait de l'utilité qu'il y aurait à
réexaminer les modalités générales de la
collaboration entre les services de la
présidence de la république et les
administrations placée sous l'autorité
du gouvernement voilà ma question
encore une fois je ne méconnais
absolument pas la gravité des faits ni
ce jour là ni aujourd'hui ce qui aurait
été particulièrement grave et ce qui
aurait porté atteinte la présence de la
public de façon particulièrement e
aiguës graves soit et qu'il n'y aurait
pas eu de réaction et pas eu de
sanctions et c'est pour ça qu on a
encore une fois insisté pour qu'une
sanction qu'il soit rapide et pour ce
qui est de l'article 40
compte tenu des éléments dont je dispose
et je n'avais pas les éléments me
permettant de penser qu'une saisine au
titre de l'article 40 serait justifié
j'ajoute pour être plus explicite
vous avez cité un nombre d'autorités qui
ont été informés au niveau du
gouvernement ou ailleurs et qu'aucune
autorité qui a eu à connaître de ces
faits n'a à ma connaissance
elles ont même suggéré l'opportunité
d'un article 40 et je crois que le
directeur de cabinet nous a par ailleurs
répondu en détail sur ce point et sur
l'analyse qu'il a lui-même fait je
conçois parfaitement qu aujourd'hui à la
lumière des fêtes connu depuis lors donc
certains je le rappelle ont conduit au
licenciement de monsieur benalla puisque
dans le courrier de notification de la
sanction il eût été dit qu'à la
prochaine faute ils seraient licenciés
de manière à ce que on est une réponse
qui soit proportionné graduée qui ne
reste certainement pas sans conséquences
dès lors que de nouveaux faits se
produire et ça a été le cas et donc je
maintiens que la lumière des faits
connus depuis la sanction peut
apparaître insuffisante mais que
symétriquement au regard des éléments
connus le 2 mai cette sanction était
proportionné et j'ajoute que j'ai
entendu hier
éric morvan le dgpn qui indiquait hier
devant les députés que placé dans la
même situation il aurait probablement
pris la même décision qui ne s'explique
pas si messieurs benalla n'avait pas une
fonction que je déchirais que je
définirais sommairement comme celle d'un
garde du corps
et si ils n'étaient pas habilités à
porter une arme pendant les déplacements
officiels
s'il n'en portait pas non plus pendant
les déplacements privés pourquoi la
présidence de la république et les
services du ministère de l'intérieur qui
ont instruit cette demande
ont-elles favoriser l'obtention d'un
permis de port d'armes
il ya là est pour nous une sorte d'
incohérences qu'elle pouvait être
l'utilité pour la présidence de la
république que cet agent est un permis
de port d'armes
non j'ai oublié de vous êtes présent de
me relancer sur la question du port
d'armes qui est une question que je n'ai
pas répondu et à laquelle je dois
commencer par répondre que je n'ai pas
eu à connaître de la question du port
d'armé d'alexandre reynal a simplement
parce que comme je vous l'indiquais
compte tenu des responsabilités qui sont
les miennes je ne mords on pourra
revivre deux questions même si encore
une fois je pense que ce sont des
questions qui ne relèvent pas du champ
de cette commission en tout cas qui
relèvent très clairement de
l'organisation interne des services de
la présidence de la république mais en
tout état de cause je n'ai pas eu à
connaître de 7
de l'attribution des modalités
d'attribution du port d'armes un
monsieur benalla mais aussi bien de
semble-t-il le préfet de police que le
directeur de cabinet est présent dans un
public vous on vous en répondu sur ce
point est à la fois dans les modalités
de l'attribution par la préfecture de
police donc du cadre juridique dans
laquelle s'inscrivent et il me semble
que ce cadre juridique est liée à la
fonction et non pas lorsque si ç'avait
été une attribution par le ministère de
l'intérieur liés à un risque
le concernant tout particulièrement et
ça n'était pas le cas nous but est
justement
et qu'est ce qui dans sa fonction roth
d'être utile pour la présidence de la
république que monsieur bénard est un
permis de port d'armes
franchement je je je suppose tout
simplement que comme vous l'avait
indiqué le dispositif de sécurité est
adapté à l'intensité de la de la menace
et au contexte dans lequel se situe
président de la république il est
toujours j'insiste il est tout jouer
tout à fait il y à des services et ce
sont toujours ces services qui sont en
charge
c'est toujours le gspr qui est en charge
lorsque le présent d'un public est en
déplacement
je pense simplement je suppose que dans
certaines circonstances il a été jugé
qu' il pouvait être utile que d'autres
puissent apporter leur concours
mais vous les interrogez il ne reste pas
moins j insiste sur ce point monsieur le
sénateur parce que vous avez l'air de
trouver ça curieux mais c'est ainsi
c'est toujours le j'espère qu'ils aient
sur la protection président la
république le chef de jesper l'a dit
alors je vous remercie madame benbassa
vous souhaitiez je crois poser une
question oui merci à visionner le
président monsieur le secrétaire général
il y a eu une mise à pied à l'endroit de
monsieur banal en début mai c'est donc
une sanction vous pas pour reconnaissez
vous c'est vous même qui avait parlé
d'une faute
je ne savais pas jusque là que la
sanction appelée récompense je lis sur
le fac similé de la déclaration qu'a
fait monsieur benalla auprès de
l'administration fiscale
attestant son changement d'un dress ce
changement d adresse qui prend effet le
9 juillet indique 11 quai branly
donc il ya quand même un problème n'est
ce pas il a été récompensé il a eu son
appartement on ce quai branly puisque il
fait un changement d'adressé
deuxièmement je voudrais faire une
rectification quand même il ya j'ai posé
la question sur la suspension du
traitement de monsieur ben alla et votre
votre collègue monsieur tron star a
répondu que les 15 jours de suspension
feront l'objet d'une retenue sur les
droits à congés qu'ils avaient en
reliquat au titre de l'année 2010 est
pourtant il me semble que les tests les
textes applicables sont claires j'ai
fait vérifier
je cite un congé non pris ne donne pas
lieu à ne donne lieu à aucune indemnité
compensatrice
comment monsieur benalla peut-il ainsi
percevoir une indemnité compensatrice
pour des congés non payés
je vous donne une petite indication au
cas où ils seraient licenciés pour faute
lorsqu'on est licencié pour faute
un contractuel public enfin lorsqu'on
contractuels et licencié cela n'ouvre
pas normalement droit au versement ni
d'une indemnité de licenciement ni même
à une indemnité compensatrice de congés
annuels est ce que monsieur benalla a
été licencié pour faute
maintenant les spas et de telles
indemnités lyon elle était versée
malgré cela mais merci c'est une
question très précise monsieur de ce
créneau
oui il ya deux questions il y en a une
sur le logement et une sur sur le
licenciement
enfin sur la sanction alors comme jeu
comme je vous le disais dans mon propos
enfin dans leur réponse à la première
question je ne la gestion interne du
personnel de l'elysée relève de la
responsabilité du dilatoire cabinet il
me il me rends compte donc je ne cherche
pas du tout l'esquivé le moindre
responsabilité mais je ne suis pas
intervenu
et je n'interviens pas dans
l'attribution des logements à la à la
résidence de
de l'alma dont je crois d'ailleurs le
dha liste est assez assez largement
diffusé et qui est qui en fait
accueil très majoritairement mais la
cour des comptes a déjà écrit
abondamment sur ce sur ce sujet des
personnes qui sont qui font l'objet
d'une nécessité absolue de de service et
à dia dont la des exigences de
disponibilité sont sont particulièrement
fortes
donc je ne suis pas intervenu dans
l'attribution du logement et donc je ne
vous reviendrai pas sur ce que le
directeur de cabinet a pu vous dire sur
cette question et juillet 2010 huit jeux
j'entends bien je vous dis simplement
que je n'ai pas eu à connaître de
l'attribution de ce logement et de très
franchement je ne je ne je ne connais
pas les détails de cette de cette
attribution
ab oui je vous le dis très directement
je ne m'occupe pas et très franchement
je pense que il est logique
encore une fois je reviens sur cette
question de hiérarchie des
responsabilités
je fais beaucoup de choses je peux vous
dire je travaille un petit peu mais je
ne m'occupe pas de l'attribution de tous
les logements
au sein de l'elysée fût ce à monsieur
benalla donc je m'en voudrais vous
donner une information erronée sur ce
sujet qui ne serait qu'une information
rapportée ce sur effet sur la date la
taille de l'appartement où effectivement
et pour ce qui est de son delà de la
sanction
je reviendrai simplement sur la la
séquence qui au moment où la section la
sanction est prise il ya un
avertissement avec pouvant conduire à un
licenciement mais la décision du
licenciement
elle n'est pas prise à ce moment là bien
évidemment donc on considère que la
sanction est appliquée pour des raisons
de sécurisation juridique sur lequel je
reviens pas lié au terme de deux
suspensions et les nécessités d'un
assurer la robustesse la retenue le
directeur salaires s'est révélé trop
fragile et du coup la sanction à la
retenue sur salat la modalité de retenue
a pris la forme d'une annulation quelque
sorte qu'ils de retenue de jours de
congé et ce quand à son licenciement
oui c'est un cetain c'est à la suite
d'une nouvelle faute effectivement qu'il
a été qu'il a été licencié dans le cadre
juridique légal
je remercie monsieur buffet merci
monsieur le président monsieur morvan
hier également monsieur strzoda vous
même en début de cette réunion
vous nous avez indiqué ne pas savoir ne
pas avoir connaissance des relations
extrêmement tendues
je mesure mes mots entre monsieur
benalla et le j'espère la réponse est ce
matin dans ce grand journal du soir où
monsieur benalla déclare semble-t-il des
frictions oui mais sous forme de non
dits moi j'ai toujours fait les choses
n'ont pas pour ma personne mais dans
l'intérêt du président mais il ya des
gens qui sont formatés d'une autre façon
on fait le sale boulot et on s'expose
forcé
et quand on s'expose face à ce type de
personne ils vous disent oui avec un
sourire mais il ne l'oublient pas trois
points de suspension
je ne fais pas partie du club je le
ressens mais je dois en faire
abstraction car la seule chose qui
compte c'est que le président soit bien
ne pensez vous pas monsieur le
secrétaire général que cette déclaration
non seulement conforte les tensions
existantes mais de surcroît le rôle et
l'implication de monsieur benalla dans
la sécurité du président de la
république c'est de secrétaire général
je ne fais aucune conjectures sur une
déclaration que je n'ai pas lu et que je
découvre
non mais bien sûr je découvre en vous
écoutant je répèterai qu' aucun incident
ne met jamais remonté aucun je répèterai
que j'ai eu des retours très positifs
sur le trajet qui mène à la je n'ai
aucun problème à dire je les assume que
c'est quelqu'un qui était très engagé
extrêmement dévoués extrêmement
disponibles comme je voulais dit moi je
n'ai jamais travaillé directement avait
avec lui ses deux collaborateurs directs
dont il ne faisait pas partie mais je
n'ai que des que des retours positifs
sur son engagement et son dévouement et
je pense et le président la république
s'est exprimé sur ce sujet hier est
effectivement qui fait écho à un élément
que fait valoir alexandre benalla sur le
fait c'était quelqu'un qui avait un
profil différent et c'est tout à fait
vrai qu alexandre reynal a un profil
différent par rapport à au type de
profil qu'on rencontre fréquemment dans
les couloirs de l'elysée je pense que
c'est aussi cet opposant à publica dit
que c'était quelque chose nous pouvons
être fiers parce que c'est important
aussi que les services la présence d'un
public soit à l'image de notre pays et
le fait que mais qu' il est il et il est
un profil evian ce qui est ce qui est en
revanche important c'est que chacun
reste dans le cadre de ses
responsabilités et ça c'est ça la
question
c'est bien celle que de vous poser
d'accord mais je répondais et sénateurs
qui m'interroger sur une question il
exactement 2 mais c'était pas c'était
précisément pas le sujet que de la
question et de l'intervention de
l'interview plutôt d'alexandre benalla
que l'adhésion de ses fonctions mais
c'était la question d'ambiance à terre
moi je vous réponds en tout cas sur la
dimension différence qu'effectivement il
ya différentes diversité je pense que ce
n'est pas forcément un problème
et quant au fait qu' il ait pu exister
des tensions dont je ne suis pas au
courant
ça me semblerait assez naturel je
connais peu d'organisation
dans lesquelles vous avez plusieurs
dizaines de personnes dans lequel vous
n'avez jamais attention enfin en tout
cas c'était c'est assez rare et d'autant
qu effectivement du fait de et tous ceux
qui ont eu à connaître du fonctionnement
de ces chefferies de cabinet savent que
l'équipe de la chefferie de cabinet sont
toujours des gens qui sont assez
jalouser parce que ils ont cette
dimension de proximité avec l'autorité
qui suscite toujours une certaine une
certaine envie et donc vous constaterez
toujours que dans un communiqué
ministériel présidentielle prix
ministériel le chef de cabinet au son
équipe rapprochée qui ont un accès
direct à la personnalité sont toujours
des gens qu'on con con envira j'ai passé
la journée du 1er mai au bureau pour
travailler mais aussi pour suivre les
différentes manifestations qui se
déroulaient sur le territoire national
et notamment la manifestation qui s'est
déroulée à paris qui avait été annoncé
comme une manifestation à haut risque
ceci pour me permettre d'informer le
secrétaire général de l'elysée et le
chef de l'état qui vous le savez à ce
moment là se trouvait en australie et
était sur le point de se rendre en
nouvelle calédonie j'ai appris le
lendemain matin c'est à dire le 2 mai
qu'au cours de ces manifestations qui
s'étaient déroulé à à paris et cours
desquelles de nombreux incidents se sont
produits un chargé de mission des
services de l'elysée plus précisément du
cabinet avait eu un comportement
inapproprié et choquant je les a pris en
prenant connaissance d'une vidéo qui n'a
été montrée par un collaborateur le
matin en arrivant au bureau vers les 9
heures et cette vidéo montrée à la fois
des scènes d'affrontements violents
avec des des poursuites entre
manifestants et forces de l'autre des
jets de projectiles qui visiblement
n'émanait pas des forces de l'ordre et
tout ceci dans une très grande confusion
et en même temps une scène de
l'intervention de policiers au sein
desquelles se trouvaient ceux chargés
mission qui semble être monsieur
benallal j'ai donc immédiatement
convoqué l'intéressé pour lui demander
de de s'expliquer et il m'a confirmé
qu'il était bien présent sur les lieux
que c'est bien lui qu'on voyait sur
cette vidéo
et il a justifié son comportement en
indiquant qu' il voulait aider les
policiers pris à partie par des
manifestants violents qui est qui
jetaient des projectiles sur les forces
de l'ordre
je les ai informés que sa participation
à cette opération de maintien de l'ordre
ne faisait pas partie de sa mission
d'observateurs et que son comportement
était inacceptable que cela constituait
une faute et qu'une sanction serait
prise j'ai immédiatement porté ces
informations à la connaissance du
secrétaire général de l'elysée pour
qu'il en informe le chef de l'état lors
du point quotidien que font le chef de
l'état et le secrétaire général lorsque
le chef de l'état est en déplacement à
l'étranger
le secrétaire général qu'on a informé le
chef de l'état en indiquant qu un
collaborateur
monsieur benalla avait eu un
comportement fautif et qu'une sanction
serait prise j'ai pris en tant que
directeur de cabinet directeur des
services de la présidence
la sanction qui comporte une suspension
de 15 jours sans traitement
c'est à dire une mise à pied une
exclusion temporaire du service
une autre sanction qui est la
modification des missions qui était
confiée à monsieur benalla en lui
retirant sa participation à
l'organisation des déplacements publics
du président de la république c'est à
dire très clairement mesdames et
messieurs une rétrogradation
et tout ceci a fait l'objet d'une lettre
que je lui est notifiée le 3 mai et qui
précisait également que en cas de
nouveaux comportements fautifs
il s'ensuivrait un licenciement certains
considèrent que ces sanctions n'étaient
pas adaptés et votre commission monsieur
le président me permettra de vous
apporter toutes les réponses sur ce
point en cet instant je voulais
également dire que je mesure
parfaitement le trouble que le
comportement de ce collaborateur a pu
susciter notamment chez
nos forces de sécurité c'est pourquoi je
voudrais dire devant vous parce que je
sais que partager cette appréciation que
le chef de l'état mesure chaque jour
l'engagement des forces de sécurité pour
assurer notre sécurité au quotidien pour
lutter contre la menace terroriste
pour garantir le maintien de l'ordre est
donc garantir l'état de droit je voulais
le dire et lire également aux forces de
sécurité au nom du chef de l'état que la
sécurité du chef de l'état ne peut être
assuré que sous l'autorité et le
contrôle des policiers et des gendarmes
ce qui s'est passé mesdames et messieurs
c'est un comportement individuel fautif
pour lequel une information judiciaire
est ouverte et pour lequel une sanction
disciplinaire a été immédiatement prises
il appartient à présent la justice
d'établir les responsabilités des
individus poursuivis et donc j'ai la
volonté en nous présentant devant vous
de répondre de manière précise et
complète à toutes vos questions le
président de la république en autorisant
à venir devant vous a souhaité à
contribuer à la manifestation de la
vérité
il m'a néanmoins demandé de rappeler le
cadre juridique dans lequel j'interviens
devant vous je dois veiller à respecter
le principe de séparation des pouvoirs
qui ne permettra pas de répondre aux
questions portant sur des faits non lieu
à une information judiciaire et à celles
portant sur l'organisation interne de la
présidence de la république
on aurait compris qu'il fût exfiltré
dans un service administratif le fait
qu'ils se retrouvent à accueillir les
bleus à roissy avec quelques
conversations avec les gendarmes et
quelques problèmes le fait qu'ils se
retrouvent dans cet autobus
le fait qu'il se retrouve à l'hommage au
panthéon le fait qu'ils se retrouvent le
14 juillet non seulement à la l'entrée
mais dans la tribune
ciel fait qu' il y a quand même une
confusion qui subsiste est à cet égard
je voulais vous demander
et d'ailleurs vous l'avez licenciés et
je vous ne l'avez pas licenciée le 2 mai
ou le 3 mai mais finalement après la
publication d'un article de presse
même si eux quelques propos récents qui
n'était pas d'une grande amabilité à
l'égard de la presse mais vous ne l'avez
licenciés eux il y a deux jours ou trois
jours ou quelques jours et pas le droit
mais vous savez prix choisi c'est une
autre fonction une autre sanction
j'arrête là pour faire plaisir à
monsieur le président mais je pense
monsieur le préfet que vous m'avez
compris mon cher président un tueur
j'ai aussi plaisir à vous écouter mais
je suis un petit peu comptable de
l'expression de chacun
alors messieurs le directeur pourriez
vous apporter une réponse à notre
collègue
oui monsieur le président je vais
essayer d'être précis et et concis il ya
trois questions dans la caisse dans
leurs interventions de monsieur le
sénateur
le licenciement les missions publiques
que monsieur bénard a continué
d'effectuer
et puis son son rôle dans le dispositif
de sécurité sur le licenciement
vous dites monsieur le sénateur
finalement vous l'avait licencié
récemment quand l'article du monde et
par une eau non non il a été licencié
parce qu'il ya eu de nouveaux
comportements fautifs
il ya eu de nouveaux comportements
fautifs lesquels
c'est ce comportement fautif fait
l'objet d'une information judiciaire qui
a été lancée suite à un article 40 que
j'ai fait donc je vous ai une
information je ne peux pas une
information que vous nous donniez terre
qui avait été lancé quelques heures
avant que nous fassions un signalement
au procureur pour être plus précis il ne
vous ne pouvez pas nous dire de quels
faits il s'agit c'est la détention et au
recel de documents eu d'accord voilà
donc le licenciement d'accord
et le licenciement a été pris sur le
fondement de la lettre du 3 mai qui lui
a infligé la sanction dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure
récidive en cas de récidive ou de
nouveaux comportements fautifs
licenciement donc ça a été fait lors
l'émission de de monsieur benalla après
en fait après le 1er mai puisque j'ai
dit que ces missions ont été redéployés
pour simplifier les choses donc on lui a
retiré une mission extrêmement
valorisante qui consiste à participer à
l'organisation des déplacements publics
du présent à public et donc on l'a
recentré sur des fonctions internes au
palais organisation de grande
manifestation au palais de l'elysée les
grands rassemblements des invitations et
donc c'est à ce titre là qu'il a été
mobilisée dans le cadre de la réception
de l'équipe de france vainqueur de la
coupe du monde qui était invité par le
chef de l'état le 16 juillet jeu je
rappelle que la finale de la coupe du
monde a eu lieu le 15 juillet et que les
l'équipe de france est arrivée à
l'elysée vingt-quatre heures après
donc nous avons eu 24 heures mesdames et
messieurs pour organiser en liaison avec
la fédération française de football
l'arrivée des bleus à paris et leur
accueil à l'elysée où les attendaient
3000 invités notamment des jeunes qui
venaient de tous les départements
présentent la république avait souhaité
inviter
les français à cette à cet accueil
en 24 heures il a fallu mobiliser
énormément de monde mais surtout cette
cet événement était encadrée de manière
très stricte par des contraintes qui
nous était imposé par la fédération
française de football qui se voulait
absolument que les joueurs de l'équipe
de france puisse quitter le palais de
l'elysée à 20 heures après l'accueil
après l'accueil à l'elysée et comme
l'avion comme l'avion qui les ramenait
de moscou atterrissait à 17 heures à
roissy et qu' il y avait entre rossi et
le palais de l'elysée la descente des
champs elysées qui en 1998 avait pris
quatre heures avait pris quatre heures
il a fallu mettre en place un dispositif
qui garantissait que le bus avec
l'équipe de france et leurs
accompagnateurs serait au palais de
l'elysée au plus tard à 19h30 où les
attendaient 3000 personnes qui venaient
de toute la france et pour qu'à 20h et
puissent rejoindre leurs familles et ils
avaient également des obligations ayant
donc parce qu'ils ont changé leur
programme mais ça nous le savions pas
mana mana mais là c'est nathan tout ça
ce sont bien sûr les versions de ce
directeur et la somme si je comprends
bien
monsieur benalla répond toujours présent
quand il s'agit de prêter main forte aux
forces de sécurité et que leurs
effectifs sont insuffisants
monsieur le président le le cortège où
cette mission où effectivement il était
présent dans le bus pour nous informer
de la progression du bus pour que nous
on puisse gérer les 3000 personnes à
l'elysée ce n'était pas une mission de
sécurité
c'était une mission de liaison de
liaison avec le palais de l'elysée où
nous nous devions accueillir 3000
invités les faire patienter voilà et
surtout s'assurer qu'ils arriveraient
dans de bonnes conditions
s'agissant du 14 juillet cette mission
ne lui a pas été retirée et donc il
était toujours chargé d'accueillir les
invités du président de la république le
14 juillet 2018 et est depuis de
s'assurer de leur bon emplacement
la cérémonie organisée en l'honneur de
mon email et son époux l'a31 isation
nous avions besoin là d'un coordinateur
entre l'arrivée du cortège du président
de la république et l'arrivée des deux
les deux cercueils pour bien là aussi
coordonner la progression de celle de
ses deux cortèges pour l'entrée au
panthéon
donc c'était une une mission qui était
entièrement pilotée par l'elysée et on
avait besoin d'un agent de liaison qui
n'était pas du tout dans un déplacement
public
c'était pas forme pourquoi fallait-il
que ce fût bly lui pourquoi fallait-il
que ce fut lui il ya beaucoup de
personnel susceptible mais où est-ce
qu'ils aient fait les vraiment dans ses
missions très visible très symbolique
qui lui cette personne qui sait tous
comportés commencé il ya d'autres
personnes
d'abord monsieur le sénateur les
effectifs du cabinet du président de la
république sont extrêmement contraint
réduit et donc pour ce type pour ce type
d'événements inédits exceptionnel on
mobilise ce qu'ils savent faire ce
qu'ils savent faire et il est vrai que
monsieur benalla avait cette capacité
d'organisateurs et donc qu'on a on a
mobilisé les ressources disponibles et
c'était une mission qui ne devais pas le
faire apparaître publiquement
c'était une mise en mission logistique
alors je voudrais revenir également sur
la question que vous avez évoqué sur la
la participation de monsieur benalla à
la sécurité rapprochée du président la
république et sa proximité
je veux je dois répéter que monsieur
benalla n'était pas chargée d'assurer
personnellement la sécurité rapprochée
du président de la république
qu'effectivement il soit à proximité du
président de la république il faut
placer cette présence dans sa mission de
coordination de plusieurs services
lorsque le président la république dit
je vais changer mon programme je vais
aller saluer les personnes qui sont là
bas sur la place plutôt que d'aller dans
l'équipement public que je doit
inaugurer gérer un peu plus tard eh bien
il le dit à qui il le disait un monsieur
bénard pour que celui-ci répercute ce
changement de programme au cortège qu'il
faut déplacer le cortège au dispositif
de sécurité qu'il faut déployer
voilà donc c'est vrai que il y à des
photographies qui montre que
comme vous dites ils sont à 20
centimètres l'un de l'autre mais on ne
voit que ses photographies mais lorsque
monsieur benalla devait courir un autre
bout d'une place pour s'assurer que le
président de la république pouvait venir
serrer des mains en toute sécurité
non on voit pas les photos ce directeur
hui nous attendons vos explications
ah oui elles sont pour nous un peu
contrat cui tiges parce qu'effectivement
nous voyons ce collaborateur dans de
nombreuses circonstances et dans une
attitude une posture qui évoque quand
même très fortement celle d'un garde du
corps et nous avons cru comprendre que
c'est bien la fonction qu'ils avaient
occupée pendant la campagne
présidentielle et nous pouvons faire
l'hypothèse peut-être fausse que le lien
de confiance qui s'était établi à cette
occasion n'a pas été rompue après
l'élection du président de la république
que celui ci s'en est largement remis
pour sa protection rapprochée à un jeune
collaborateur dont il avait éprouvé les
talents ces salles hypothèse oui que
vous que vous ne demandez pas
complètement mais vous essayez de re
situer l'action de ce collaborateur dans
un cadre plus formel plus organisés mais
ce que la réalité on nous a beaucoup
parlé des réalités de la vie n'est pas
plutôt celle que je décris monsieur le
président je ne peux pas contester qu'il
ya de nombreuses photographies qui
montre cette proximité mais je prends le
pari devant vous qu'il existe autant de
photographies mais qu'elles ne sont pas
publiées qui montre que le chef de
cabinet dans cette position que
l'adjoint au chef de cabinet dans cette
position seulement évidemment ici ils
ont la chance de ne pas être assez
cabinet porte il une arme at il des
oreillettes pour s'exprimer et un
système de communication une boucle mais
il n'est pas une batterie de sécurité
ils n'assurent pas la sécurité
rapprochée la callas comment dire il est
pas garde du corps du président de la
république monsieur benalla ne portait
jamais d'armes lorsque il était dans un
déplacement public du président de la
république messieurs
ben alla ne portait jamais d'armes quand
il accompagnait le président de la
république dans un déplacement officiel
donc son permis de port d'armé était
exclusivement destinée à lui permettre
de porter une arme pour les déplacements
privés
ce n'était pas précisée dans
l'autorisation et d'ailleurs je ne sais
pas si il a été amené à porter une arme
dans les déplacements privés
j'ai dit que j'ai ce que j'ai dit
pourquoi at il demandé et obtenu un
permis de port d'armes si ils
n'emportaient jamais ce n'était pas dans
l'utilité du service alors je je ne j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure que en tant que
responsable direct de la sécurité du
chef de l'état il m'a paru à moi utile
que dans certaines circonstances il y en
plus du gs père qui est chargé de la
protection rapprochée
une personne qui puisse la voir non
c'est tout je ne peux pas j'ai voulu
comprendre et expliquer dans le détail
comment s'organise la sécurité du chef
de l'état est ce que l'agent comptable
de l'elysée est peu nous produire les
écritures montrant que monsieur ben alla
n'a touché que la moitié de son
traitement le mois où il a été
sanctionné
merci merci chers collègues monsieur le
directeur monsieur benalla a été recruté
en qualité d'agent contractuel c'est un
contrat de droit public et donc pour la
sanction nous avons effectivement fait
application du décret de 1986 qui
prévoient l'échelle des sanctions vous
l'avez rappelé madame la sénatrice
l'avertissement l'exclusion temporaire
et le licenciement
voilà donc la halle la sanction de
suspension de quinze jours en fait c'est
une exclusion temporaire
kiki a été qui a été prononcée qui a été
prononcée le conseil de discipline n'a
pas été saisie parce que nous n'avons
pas de conseils de discipline dans les
services de l'elysée est gelée indiqué
ce qui a primé dans dans notre décision
c'était la rapidité prendre une sanction
immédiate adaptée et proportionnée
ce qui a été fait
la première question c'était à huy
document tout à fait ats alors
excusez-moi je vais monsieur benalla a
touché pour le mois de mai son salaire
intégral en revanche en revanche les 15
jours de suspension se feront l'objet
d'une retenue sur les droits à congés
qu'ils avaient en reliquat au titre de
l'année 2007 il avait 10 ha et là de
très nombreux jours de congés auquel il
a droit
le titre d'année 2010 est et dans son
solde avant licenciement ces congés nous
serons pas payer mes chers collègues la
réponse de monsieur le directeur a le
mérite de la franchise est je crois
qu'il faut le lui reconnaître ce 1er mai
aurait pu être un 1er mai si je puis
dire traditionnel axée sur les
revendications syndicales
mais un certain nombre d'individus en
avait décidé autrement et la lettre vous
le savez extrêmement violent en effet
dès le début de la manifestation se
forment un avant cortège plus important
que le cortège lui-même avec au milieu
d'où 100 black blocs qui se cagouler ils
traversent le pont e d'austerlitz et
gagne le boulevard de l'hôpital où il se
livre un déferlement de violence
saccageant plusieurs commerces un
mcdonald's est un concessionnaire
automobile
je crois que tous les français ont
encore dans l'esprit ces images qui
étaient d'une violence totalement inouï
grâce un dispositif de maintien de
l'ordre important 15 cents policiers
gendarmes
la progression et fauteur de trouble est
stoppée mais une partie d'entre eux a
lancé le mot d'ordre de poursuivre la
casse place de la contrescarpe il
voulait dans
projet initial aller jusqu'au
commissariat du xiiie arrondissement que
nous venions d'inaugurer il y avait
quinze jours de manière à pouvoir
l'incendié ils ont été stoppés mais il
se retrouve à la contrer ça à 19h30
je me trouve à la préfecture de police
pour faire un débriefing opérationnel
sur les événements de la journée avec le
préfet de police dans son bureau
nous gagnons ensuite ensemble la salle
de commandement pour suivre les
affrontements qui se poursuivent alors
place de la contrescarpe nous saluons la
quarantaine de personnes présentes parmi
lesquelles monsieur benalla dont je le
répète aujourd'hui je pensais alors
qu'il était un policier chargé de la
sécurité du président je l'avais en
effet comme je les dis croisés pendant
la campagne présidentielle mais elle
était toujours parmi des dizaines de
personnes chargées de la sécurité du
candidat policiers agents de sécurité
service d'ordre dans marche
monsieur gibelin et son adjoint me faut
une présentation du dispositif
puis nous fixons un autre attention sur
les écrans car les violences continuent
avec l'utilisation de mobilier urbain et
vous savez qu'à paris et en a en ce
moment beaucoup pour tenté d'ériger des
barricades et des interpellations sont
toujours en cours notamment dans le
secteur de la contrescarpe comme l'a dit
hier le préfet de police
il y assure la journée du 1er mai
environ deux cent soixante seize
interpellations dans trente et une sur
la seule place de la contrescarpe les
opérations est terminée je rentre à bout
puis à 23 heures je me rends avec le
premier ministre et le préfet de police
au commissariat du xiiie arrondissement
de paris
celui dont je vous ai dit qu'il était la
cible les black blocks
nous saluons les troupes présentes et
avant une discussion avec elle sur les
événements de la journée
le
lendemain matin 2 mai dès 7h30
je participe à l'émission les 4 vérités
sur france 2 où j'ai eu l'occasion de
revenir sur les événements de la veille
et leur gestion par les forces de
l'ordre à 8h30 revenant de cette
émission je préside une réunion d'états
majors avec les principales directions
du ministère où nous évoquons les
événements qui ont émaillé le 1er mai au
moment où l'ordre du jour concernant le
1er mai est épuisé
je laisse la présidence mon directeur de
cabinet et vais m'entretenir après avec
la directrice de la police judiciaire
avec le directeur général de la sécurité
intérieure pour faire un point sur la
menace terroriste qui elle aussi nous
semblait extrêmement important je ne
croise donc pas à ce moment là le préfet
de police à la réunion d'état major où
il est représenté par ses collaborateurs
mais je lui fait savoir que je souhaite
me rendre avec lui boulevard de
l'hôpital pour à la fois me rendre
compte par moi même de l'itinéraire
emprunté à part l'anif manifestation de
la façon dont la manoeuvre a été
effectué et aussi pour évaluer les
dégâts causés
nous nous entretenons alors avec les
commerçants qui nous raconte des faits
d'une extrême violence et en particulier
le concessionnaire qui avait vu ses
voitures incendiées nous raconte les
choses absolument insensé elle nous dit
à ce moment là j'ai eu véritablement
très peur le préfet de police leur dit
qu'ils vont être indemnisé dans les
meilleurs délais à ce moment là ni le
préfet de police ni mon cabinet ne m'ont
encore informé d'une vidéo montrant des
violences contre les manifestants place
de la contrescarpe à l'issue j'ai un
déjeuner avec un membre de ma famille
dans un restaurant de la rue de lille ce
n'est qu'à mon retour au ministère
aux alentours de 15h que mon directeur
et mon chef de cabinet m'apprennent de
l'existence de la vidéo
et ne prennent que les violences ont été
commises par monsieur benalla dont
j'apprends alors qu'il n'était pas comme
je le pense policiers mais chargé de
mission à l'elysée se présentant lui
mais lui seul comme le chef de cabinet
adjoint du président de la république
mondiaux acteurs de cabinet mme assure
alors que le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république c'est à dire
le supérieur hiérarchique de monsieur
benalla et le préfet de police
connaissent les faits et s'en sont
entretenus ensemble c'est lui aussi qui
ma vie ce que le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république lui a
confirmé dans la soirée qu'il je cite
considérer l'action de monsieur benalla
comme inacceptable et qu'une sanction
disciplinaire allaient être prises
j'apprendrai beaucoup plus tard le 21
juillet que le préfet de police avait
fait rédiger une note technique sur les
faits qui l'a reconnu lui-même ne
m'avoir jamais transmis ce 3 mai je
considère donc que les faits sont pris
en compte au niveau adapté à partir de
ce jour-là et jusqu'au 18 juillet je
n'entends plus parler de monsieur
benalla je me concentre alors sur
d'autres évènements gestion le lendemain
et 3 mai d'une manifestation cheminots
de la préparation du rassemblement du
samedi 5 mai organisé par la france
insoumise afin que les choses ne
dégénèrent pas comme elle l'avait fait
pour le 1er mai je prépare les
évacuations des facultés de toulouse le
mirail le 9 mai de rennes le 14 mai je
prépare la deuxième évacuation de notre
dame des landes
enfin je gère malheureusement les suites
de l'attentât de paris 2e et
fera vous le savez une victime le samedi
12 mai jean vient désormais la journée
du 18 juillet ce jour là j'apprends dans
l'après midi vers 15 heures que des
journalistes du monde prépare un article
sur les événements du 1er mai qui paraît
aux alentours de 20h30
le lendemain matin je prends
connaissance des images parues sur les
réseaux sociaux
montrant que monsieur benalla portait le
1er mai un brassard de police et qu'il
détenait une radio je demande donc
immédiatement qu'on prépare une saisie
de l'igpn pour déterminer les conditions
dans lesquelles il a pu bénéficier de
tels équipements
entre temps j'ai un rendez vous avec
monsieur jean pierre chevènement
président de la fondation pour l'islam
de france que je prépare avec une demi
conseillère et j'ai ensuite un déjeuner
avec des journalistes et à 15 heures
dehors des questions au gouvernement au
sénat
j'annonce que nous allons saisir l'igpn
à mon retour
j'apprends que trois policiers de la
direction de l'ordre public et de la
circulation en donner à monsieur benalla
les banques de vidéo protection des
événements de la contrescarpe nous
transmettons ces nouvelles informations
à l'igpn et le matin du 20 juillet je
suspends sur proposition du préfet de
police
les trois policiers concernés voilà donc
mesdames et messieurs la chronologie
précise des faits tels que je les ai
vécues ces précisions chronologique
apporter je souhaiterais dans un second
temps éclaircir quelques points
certains après mon audition à
l'assemblée nationale se sont étonnés
que je n'ai pas eu connaissance de
certains faits les auditions et du
préfet de police du directeur de l'ordre
public et de la circulation dans la même
journée ont montré qu'aucun d'eux qui
pourtant était au coeur de la manoeuvre
n'avait été ni informée de la
participation de monsieur benalla aux
opérations d'ordre public ni de sa venue
au centre de commandement de la
préfecture de police
comment dès lors si cela met
qui effectivement est fait à la
manoeuvre ne connaissais pas aurais-je
pu savoir sur le port da je confirme que
monsieur benalla s'était tourné en
janvier 2017 vers mon prédécesseur pour
solliciter une autorisation
elle lui avait été refusée le 12 avril
le 21 juin 2017
il s'était de nouveau adressé à mes
services pour que sa demande soit
réétudié demande à laquelle mon cabinet
n'avait pas donné suite
considérant que les conditions
juridiques n'étaient pas réunies comme
l'a dit le préfet de police
ce sont donc ces services par lui
directement qui ont finalement attribué
à monsieur benalla une autorisation de
port d'armes délivré le 13 octobre 2010
est sans que mon cabinet en aient été
informés
pour ce qui est de l'article 40 je pense
que on y reviendra dans les débats de je
m'en tiens à ce que j'ai dit hier devant
l'assemblée nationale
comme je lé rappeler je vous donnerai
tout à l'heure quelques exemples les
ministres de l'intérieur successifs ont
évidemment eu connaissance par les
services de renseignements de multiples
suspicion d'infraction pénale ou de
commission d'infractions pénales mais
comme mes prédécesseurs je considère que
c'est aux chefs de service à ceux qui
sont au plus près du terrain
recueillant les éléments permettant de
justifier la transmission d'un
signalement au titre de l'article 40 de
le faire je n'en ai d'ailleurs transmis
qu'un seul depuis mon arrivée tout à
l'heure je vous dirai combien mes
prédécesseurs en ont transmis il
concernait la vidéo d'un rappeur
appelant au lynchage et au meurtre d'un
policier
j'ai demandé à la direction des libertés
publiques et des affaires juridiques
d'établir la liste des articles 40
transmis par les anciens ministres de
l'intérieur
je vous la donnerai tout à l'heure il
ressort que aussi en ont fait très peu
et qu'ils concernent essentiellement des
infractions relatives à la loi de 1881
sur la liberté de la presse dernier
point
pourquoi n'avoir pas saisi dès le 2 mai
à l'igpn
comme je voulais dît j'apprends le 2 mai
que monsieur benalla n'était pas
policier je n'ai donc pas de raison
alors de saisir l'igpn
le préfet de police qui savait lui qu'il
n'était pas policier partage cette
analyse sur le fait qu' il a il l'a dit
lui même il a réuni les chefs de service
et leur dit comment se fait-il que cet
homme qui effectivement n'a aucune
permission de ma part pour participer à
une mission d'ordre public
ils participent effectivement c'est donc
seulement après avoir appris que
monsieur beynat la porte et indûment le
1er mai un brassard et qu'il détenait
une radio de police qui lui avait été
remis par on verra dans l' enquête quel
service que je saisi l'igpn
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
voilà ce que je souhaite vous dire les
éléments que je souhaite porter à votre
connaissance et vous me permettrez le
conclure comme vous l'avez fait monsieur
le président en soulignant que nous
devons la vérité aux français mais aussi
que nous la devons aux forces de l'ordre
qui eux agissent avec nous le rappelons
toujours un souci de la déontologie et
nous leur demandons nous leur rappelons
s'est inscrit dès les écoles de
formation
monsieur le ministre d'état donc sans
trop de préliminaires le préfet de
police de paris
et le directeur de l'ordre public et de
la circulation monsieur gibelin ollières
indiqué devant l'assemblée nationale que
monsieur benalla n'avait pas reçu
d'autorisation officielle de participer
en tant qu'observateur aux opérations de
maintien de l'ordre du 1er mai ils ont
également précisé que la qualité
d'observateur avait été accordée à
monsieur b dallas par monsieur laurent
simoneau chef d'état major adjoint à la
direction de l'ordre public et la
circulation sans que le directeur
lui-même n'en et été averti première
question est il normal que ni le
ministre de l'intérieur ni préfet de
police ni même leurs cabines n en ait
été informé par ailleurs le ministère de
l'intérieur at-il dès le 2 mai diligenté
une enquête interne pour obtenir des
informations sur les conditions de
participation de monsieur benalla à les
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
en effet vous avez indiqué que monsieur
b dallas ne participait pas des forces
de police mais il était sur l'opération
de maintien de l'ordre
cela signifie donc il avait été autorisé
vraisemblablement par quelqu'un qui
appartenait à ses forces de police et ça
signifiait également si on en croit tous
les syndicats qu'il devait avoir un
référent en tant qu'observateur qui ne
s'est non pas occupé de lui donc
aviez-vous diligenté une enquête interne
et enfin dans la négative pourquoi ne
pas vous être inquiétés d'un tel
dysfonctionnement
monsieur le ministre d'état comme je
viens de le dire a réuni l'ensemble de
ses cadres a diligenté une enquête
enquête interne a demandé pourquoi lui
même n'avait pas été mise au courant
c'est dans ce cadre qu ensuite est
apparue la responsabilité d'un certain
nombre de cadres subalternes puisque
c'était en hiver au numéro 3 ou 4 qui
avait été prise la décision sans que le
préfet de police ne soit effectivement
informés de ce qui se passait c'est un
peu ces relations que le préfet de
police a décrit hier comme des copinages
merci monsieur le ministre d'état madame
le rapporteur pour l'instant pas
d'autres questions monsieur le
rapporteur s'il vous plaît merci à
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre d'état je voulais vous poser
trois questions eux d'abord s'agissant
de l'application dû code de procédure
pénale vous avez dit hier que il
n'appartenait pas finalement au ministre
de l'intérieur d' appliquer l'article 40
du code de procédure pénale je voulais
vous demander en vertu de quels articles
de la loi
vous pouvez le faire cette affirmation
ensuite je peux comprendre que vous ayez
considérer qu'il revenait à d'autres
personnes qui avouent même de saisir la
justice devant la gravité évidente des
faits dont vous avez eu connaissance le
2 mai donc vous avez saisi le directeur
ou votre ministère votre directeur de
cabinet a saisi le directeur de cabinet
du président de la république mais celui
ci n'a pas plus que vous même et pas
plus que le préfet de police saisi le
ministère de la justice le procureur de
la république ni d'ailleurs le
secrétaire général de l'elysée ni
d'ailleurs le chef de cabinet du
président de la république est ce que
vous ne vous êtes pas dit logiquement au
bout d'un moment il ya quand même
quelque chose qui ne va pas il y a
quelque chose de pin acceptable et ça a
été dit depuis peu avec force
c'est à dire un personnage qui n'est pas
policier qui est connue qui se
comportent ainsi
ce qui à l'évidence et délictueux et
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
se satisferaient du fait que personne
personne ne saisisse la justice c'est la
première question que ministre d'état
s'il vous plaît alors monsieur le
co-rapporteur j'ai connaissance
quotidiennement par des notes de service
de renseignement de suspicion
d'infraction pénale ou de commission
d'infractions pénales
je considère j'ai toujours considéré
depuis mon arrivée au ministère de
l'intérieur
et comme tous mes prédécesseurs qu'il
n'appartient pas au ministre de
l'intérieur de transmettre au procureur
des signalements sur le fondement de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
à chaque fois qu'il a connaissance de la
commission d'une infraction pénale
ce n'est pas mon rôle de saisir chaque
procureur individuellement pour lui
signaler la commission d'infractions
je n'ai d'ailleurs transmis depuis ma
prise de fonction qu'un seul article 40
à la justice pour une infraction prévue
par la loi de 1881 de la presse il
concernait rappeur chez lui dit tout à
l'heure dans une vidéo appelant aux lois
ça et au meurtre d'un policier
alors ces pratiques sont elles
simplement celle du ministre de
l'intérieur actuel non j'ai regardé
combien
avait été fait de signalement par les
différents ministres et les différentes
années sur l'année 2014 monsieur soeur
et on avait 2 sur l'année 2015 y en
avait 4 sur l'année 2016 il y en avait 8
sur l'année 2016 y en a eu quatre
et là il y en a eu un et je regarde les
différents ministres l'ont ils fait non
monsieur hortefeux par exemple qui avait
un cabinet qui d'un point de vue
juridique avait quelques expériences
effectuées au cours de l'année seulement
trois signalements au titre de l'article
40 et elles se portent toutes sur des
problèmes de droit de la presse ou bien
d'incitation à la haine
monsieur le ministre d'état nous avons
découvert la sphère benalla grâce à la
vidéo protection les images de la vidéo
votre protection de paris et d'une vidéo
amateur on nous a parié dans les
auditions précédentes de l'existence de
photos et de vidéos de crs qui pourrait
s'expliquer puisqu'il était dans une
position délicate place de la
contrescarpe nous avons d'abord
découvert
monsieur alexandre benalla nous avons
ensuite découvert le commando benalla
avec monsieur vincent kraz on nous parle
maintenant d'un accompagnant monsieur
misère ski encadrant nom officiel est ce
que ses photos et ses vidéos
vont-ils avant elle nous fait
redécouvrir pardon d'autres
protagonistes sur les lieux ce que vous
avez connaissance de ces photos et que
nous font-elles visionner et pour finir
je vous demanderais s'il existe une
milice privée au sein de l'elysée
or gspr merci chers collègues et aussi
de votre concision monsieur le ministre
des reçus pour ce qui concerne monsieur
misére ce qu'est un de ses supérieurs
hiérarchiques lui demande de
l'accompagner
monsieur benalla qu'il croyait après dit
et enfin gpo
qu'il croyait à créditer je pense mais
l'anc est encore le montrera pour
participer à une opération de maintien
de l'ordre comme observateurs beaucoup
de députés de journalistes participent à
des opérations comme observateurs elles
sont strictement encadrées le préfet de
police rappelé hier ils souhaitaient que
ce soit il l'a rappelé à ces cas son
autorisation personnels qu'ils soient
donnés
parce que cela engage effectivement sa
responsabilité
merci beaucoup monsieur mise d'état
madame jacky d'euromédis et ce qui va
sortir
compte tenu des deux ce qui se passe moi
j'en découvre chaque jour sur les
personnalités
je lis les journaux comme vous et il ya
toute une partie de l'histoire de
monsieur benalla que franchement je
découvre de plus en plus je reviens pas
sur les circonstances du 1er mai sauf si
vous le souhaitez simplement pour
souligner que ça a été une journée
extrêmement difficile et les des
phénomènes de violence que l'on n'avait
jamais connu je redis que c'est le 2 mai
dans la matinée autour de 10h 10h15 que
j'ai été alertée par un appel
téléphonique venant du palais de
l'elysée sur ce que mon interlocuteur me
désigne affaires benalla et selon la
formule je suis très étonné je ne
comprends pas je lui demande de quoi il
s'agit il m'explique les choses
l'existence de cette vidéo
j'ai joint assez vite le cabinet du
ministre de l'intérieur qui m'a indiqué
être déjà informé être en liaison avec
l'elysée
j'ai demandé évidemment à mes
collaborateurs de trouver très vite
cette vidéo nous l'avons regardé
ensemble sur un grand écran dans le
bureau de mon directeur de cabinet jeudi
un grand écran parce que sur un
téléphone portable c'était petit et puis
sur le grand écran peut-être
pourrions-nous reconnaître monsieur
monsieur benalla ce qui n'était pas du
tout évident et ça ça se passe donc le
le 2 mai au matin j'ai eu contact aussi
après avoir prévenu le cabinet du
ministre de nouveau avec le palais de
l'elysée pour expliquer les choses
telles que je les avais vus à l'écran et
il était clair pour moi que le dossier
était pris en compte par ce que
j'appelle l'autorité hiérarchique
monsieur benalla était sous la
responsabilité de l'autorité
hiérarchique du directeur de cabinet de
la présidence et non pas de moi même mes
réactions en interne pour faire vite je
demande immédiatement à la direction de
l'ordre public et de la circulation
bref pourquoi et comment il était là
sachant que j'avais été très étonné la
veille au soir de croiser monsieur
benalla dans la salle de commandement où
j'avais accueilli le ministre
mais c'est en faisant le tour d'être là
et honeywell fêté sur le terrain voilà
la réponse que j'ai eu et très vite le
direct immédiatement le directeur de
l'ordre public et de la circulation m'a
dit je n'étais pas informé du fait que
monsieur benalla était ce jour là dans
nos rangs qui mène son enquête interne
qui fait apparaître le niveau
d'organisation de la venue de monsieur
benalla autorisation réponse à
sollicitations je ne sais pas les
enquêtes en cours au plan judiciaire le
diront peut-être
c'est pourquoi je dis le niveau
d'organisation et d'accueil au niveau
d'un contrôleur général chef d'état
major adjoint qui s'appelle monsieur
simonard donc il y a eu du côté de
l'elysée monsieur patrick strzoda mon
collègue ami patrick strzoda l'a dit
l'autorisation donnée par le cabinet du
président de la république à monsieur
benalla devenir le 1er mai sur le
territoire de la préfecture de police
à la préfecture de police a eu lieu au
niveau d'un contrôleur général
l'organisation de sa venue le directeur
adjoint de l'ordre public
le directeur de l'ordre public n'était
pas informé le préfet de police
encore moins voilà exactement comment
les choses se sont se sont passées pour
la connaissance de ceux de ce
déplacement
j'ai dans le
menu précisé l'enchaînement de de ces
informations successives
à ce stade je ne peux en dire plus si
vous le permettez je répondrai en
revanche très volontiers à toutes les
questions qui vont suivre j'espère ne
pas avoir été trop longs et ne pas trop
avoir trahi il engagement que j'avais
pris de ce point de vue monsieur le
président messieurs le préfet je vous
remercie
la question la plus simple qui me vient
à l'esprit est la suivante au fonds
beaucoup d'informations ont été données
sur le moment précis auquel vous même le
directeur de cabinet du ministre le
ministre le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république ont été
informés de la participation de monsieur
benalla à une opération de maintien de
l'ordre pour laquelle il était
naturellement tout à fait illégitime
qu'il importe d'un concours
nous comprenons que dès le 2 mai mais
haute autorité que j'ai cités dont vous
faites partie et qui se sont concertés
en tout cas qui ont été qui ont eu des
échanges entre elles prennent la
décision de ne pas saisir l'inspection
générale de la police nationale et de ne
pas faire usage de l'article 40 du code
de procédure pénale
je veux savoir si c'est une décision
tacite ou une décision concertée non
réponse monsieur le président relève de
la plus tôt de la catégorie de décisions
tacite il n'y a pas eu en tant que tel
de décision je vous redis de mon point
de vue comment cela a été vécu encore
une fois j'avais été alerté par le
palais de l'elysée qui j'ai fait
remonter parce que je ne pouvais analyse
et c'est donc là la surprise la
condamnation est immédiatement le bal
égaliser m'a dit que c'était lui qui
prenait en compte si vous voulez comme
autorités responsables hiérarchiques et
pour moi il était clair que c'est est à
ce niveau que ça devait se dérouler
quand l'appréciation des suites à donner
selon la formule c'est l'autorité
compétente et donc c'est ce qui m'a
guidée de manière assez simple et assez
évidente je dois le dire donc y at il eu
concertation
y at il eu ordre de ne pas utiliser
l'article 40 et c'est sûrement pas
sûrement pas c'est vous pouvez l'appeler
décision tacite mais il n'y a eu aucun
échange sur le thème faut-il faut-il pas
qui non non et non c'est donc du tacite
au terme des échanges comme vous
l'indiquez voilà comment ça s'est passé
sur le fond le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république s'est exprimé
hier vous avez eu également le l'analyse
que l'igpn a fait de ce sujet
puisqu'elle avait reçu la vidéo
mais j'ajoute que pour le préfet de
police la petite nuance supplémentaires
c'est que le débordement la faute
le manquement le dérapage personnel il
n'est pas le fait d'un fonctionnaire de
police
il n'est pas le fait d'un fonctionnaire
de police
il est le fait d'un collaborateur du de
la présidence de la république et non
pas d'un personnel placé sous mon
autorité et c'est le point qui pour moi
était cardinal dans le si vous voulez la
position qui a été qui a été la mienne
parce que moi si je vois la vidéo je
vois pas la vidéo contrairement à nos
amis de l'igpn qui ne savait pas qui
était laid
et les personnes moi quand je vois la
vidéo c'est pour que je puisse confirmer
oui c'est bien monsieur b dallas que
j'aurais été incapable de reconnaître il
a fallu vraiment qu'on voit sur un grand
écran et on était plusieurs autour de
moi pour pour l'identifier mais c'est
pas moi qui les identifiait premier
puisqu'on m'a alertée encore une fois je
crois que tout le monde l'a bien compris
cela et partant de là le manquement la
faute et qui sera devant a examinées par
les tribunaux de l'ordre judiciaire
c'est pas un fonctionnaire de police
c'est pas vous faire le policer l'igpn
est compétente et je saisi l'igpn pour
les gens qui sont sous mon autorité
meilleur exemple le 19 juillet je viens
la journée du 19 juillet pour vous
donner l'exemple
je rappelle que la veille au soir nous
avons été un certain nombre à être
alertés sur le fait que le journal le
monde allait comme on dit entre nous
sortir la vidéo benalla on va prendre
cette expression familière que tout le
monde comprend je n'ai alerté le
directeur nomme public j'ai refait le
point avec lui un de ses collaborateurs
le lendemain matin pour bien sûr
remettre en tête les faits du 1er mai
place de la contrescarpe parce que le
1er mai pour le préfet de police
ça n'a pas été que la place de la
contrescarpe je me permets de le je me
permets de le rappeler et
le lendemain je vous le rappelle enfin
en tout cas je l'indiquent devant votre
commission il était un peu avant 14
heures lorsque monsieur alain gibelin
directeur de l'ordre public demande à me
voir sans délai j'avais un déjeuner de
travail avec un collègue mais je dis
venez donc à la résidence j'ai quitté
d'ailleurs la table du déjeuner et là il
me révèle avec stupeur et un peu
effondré voilà vont le commissaire kroes
a vient de me révéler ce qu'ils ont fait
hier soir avec deux autres collègues
c'est à dire récupérer une des images un
support qui avait été pris de la scène
de la contrescarpe pour aller la porter
à monsieur benalla ma réaction est ce
assez pour répondre à la question
l'ag des fonctionnaires qui sont sous
mon autorité sous ma responsabilité est
ce que j'ai fait dans les deux heures
qui ont suivi c'est d'abord récupérer
leurs rapports écrits pour qu'ils
écrivent et pas seulement être dans le
dans l'oralité préparer la transmission
des données que je venais de recueillir
dans le cadre de l'article 40 à monsieur
le procureur de la république
j'ai personnellement appelé françois
molins ce pour le lui dire et dans le
même temps que je saisissais le
procureur de la république saisir le
ministre de l'intérieur le niveau
central et j'ai eu un échange au
téléphone avec monsieur gérard collomb
lui-même pour lui demander la suspension
immédiate de ces trois fonctionnaires et
ça a été fait dans la soirée les trois
fonctionnaires ont déposés ont déposé
leurs armes vous l'avez fait d'ailleurs
mon voisin pour pour un d'entre eux les
deux autres c'est le directeur de notre
public il a fait ça a été fait
immédiatement mais c'étaient des
fonctionnaires sous mon autorité et
c'était à moi et à personne d'autre de
prendre cette initiative
voilà vraiment le choix qui a été le
mien et comme je les dis ailleurs c'est
un choix qui m'a conduit ce jour là et
le 2 mai et le 19 juillet si je puis
dire est que je vous expose la dans la
plus totale clarté honnêteté et choses
sont très claires pour le 19 juillet
mais permettez-moi de revenir sur le 2
monsieur le préfet il y à la faute de
monsieur vénale à tout le monde en parle
il y a aussi les conditions de la faute
elles lui ont été offertes par nos
services
il y as sans doute la faute du cadre
dirigeant de la préfecture de police qui
en dehors de l'exercice de ses
compétences et de la délégation dont il
peut avoir bénéficié accorde la
possibilité à monsieur benalla d'être
accompagné par un autre fonctionnaire
pour assister aux opérations de maintien
de l'ordre que la sanction disciplinaire
infligée à monsieur benallal n'ai pu lui
être infligée que par le directeur de
cabinet du président de la république la
cause est entendue
mais monsieur simoneau qui je crois est
celui que vous visiez quand vous parliez
de copinage malsain c'est comme ça que
nous le devons interpréter car il
s'agissait sans doute de sa relation
avec monsieur benalla que vous mettiez
en cause n'est pas lui même fait l'objet
de poursuites disciplinaires que
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale pour ce qui concernait
d'éventuels dysfonctionnements de
l'administration de la police n'ait pas
été saisie
reste pour moi une question du point de
vue du bon fonctionnement de l'état et
je veux vous la poser oui et je vais
vous répondre
bien sûr j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
d'ailleurs mais je vous le redis ici
si la demande avait été soumise
ce qui n'a pas été le cas je ne l'aurais
pas refuser je voulais dit en
introduction une collaborateur du chef
de l'état autorisé par sa hiérarchie qui
souhaitent venir à la préfecture de
police je n'aurais pas dit non j'aurais
dit oui et sans aucun doute j'aurais
veiller à l'encadrement dans des
conditions
sans doute en mettant d'ailleurs auprès
de lui j'ai envie de dire en le recevant
mieux d'ailleurs en mettant auprès de
lui un cadre de plus haut de plus haut
niveau mais sur le fait de l'accueillir
je suis désolé en soi l'accueillir n'est
pas une faute
et si monsieur simonin a commis une
faute c'est pas de l'accueillir
c'est de ne pas en rendre compte à sa
hiérarchie et de cela il lui a été fait
les reproches qui convenait sous forme
d'admonestation verbal par son directeur
c'est un défaut de rendre compte alors
c'est un défaut de rendre compte en
temps donc c'est grave mais ce n'est
qu'un défaut de rendre compte
la faute c'est pas c'est pas d'avoir
accueilli c'est d'avoir organisé
l'accueil sans que son directeur été
informé ni le préfet de police
tom défaut de rendre de rendre compte
défaut de loyauté hiérarchique est
évidemment moi j'ai demandé au directeur
de l'ordre public de faire à monsieur
simonin sur ce sujet les représentations
sévère sous forme d'admonestation qui
convenait mais on ne pouvait pas aller
sur un terrain disciplinaire au delà
comme toujours la faute et la réponse de
la faute quelle est la faute c'est celle
là c'est pas le fait de lui avoir dit
oui venez c'est le fait d'avoir dit oui
venez sans que sa hiérarchie est tt
était prévenue voilà vraiment la
situation
vous parlez du contrôleur général si mon
âme permettez-moi dire un mot j'ai été
sans faiblesse vous le savez le 19
juillet mais la grave faute là qu'il a
commis le 18 juillet au soir avec deux
autres collègues ça c'est une grave
faute que d'être allé chercher de la
vidéo pour l'amener à monsieur b dallas
j'ai dit ma réaction tout à l'heure mais
cette grave faute n'enlève à rien les
mérites qu'il a eu par ailleurs vous
savez c'est un peu comme un un grand
footballeur il peut avoir marqué trois
buts lors d'un match formidable mais si
deux mois après il commet quelque chose
de dramatique
besset l'un et chez l'autre
et si vous vous souvenez faut voir le
printemps qu'on a traversé les
interventions en milieu universitaire
évacuation de la sorbonne aucune
difficulté j'ai suivi ce en direct avec
les images aucune violence
aucun pépin aucune plainte évacuation de
tolbiac
on voulait pas me croire quand j'ai fait
un communiqué à 6h30 du matin pour dire
que tout s'était bien passé et que
c'était fini qui commandait les troupes
qui est allé c'était le contrôleur
général simonin donc c'est un
professionnel aguerri et je ne peux pas
effacer ses mérites
je les rappelle devant vous tout en
soulignant par ailleurs la gravité à mes
yeux de la faute qu'il a commise et
c'est là où j'ai évoqué le copinage
malsain et la formule a été reprise
pourquoi c'est à dire que une peste de
facilité dans ce copinage malsain qui
fait qu' on pense qu'on peut comme ça en
oubliant un petit peu les des règles
hiérarchiques et les principes organiser
d organiser des choses mais le copinage
malsain
on verra ce que dit la justice quand
elles auront connaître si elle vient sur
ce terrain là c'était pas non plus de
quoi de quoi aller au-delà de ce que
j'ai fait en sa direction c'est-à-dire
d'augmenter au directeur de l'ordre
public de lui faire les représentations
qui convenait et de le faire sous forme
d'admonestation verbale ça a été fait
pour moi je vais vous répondre sur les
relations justement avec nos collègues
de la cgn notamment sachez que ces
relations étaient très très mauvaise
malgré moi je parle au nom des collègues
gradés et gardiens attention elle était
très très mauvaise d'ailleurs monsieur
benalla sans être dans la caricature
était d'après les termes de mes
collègues étaient exécrables donc
montrez vraiment ses fonctions et son
identité et avaient du mal à comprendre
que parfois il fallait attendre de
pouvoir passer ou pas peut attendre pour
pouvoir se garer etc etc
effectivement cette affaire défraye la
chronique et qui plus est je dirais la
chronique dans les reins des policiers
les policiers de terrain que nous
représentons à savoir les gardiens de la
paix pourquoi ce manifestement les les
agissements aujourd'hui en jeter une une
suspicion dans nos rangs et ont provoqué
aussi manifestement une rupture de
confiance avec la hiérarchie policière
rupture de confiance qui était déjà
palpable
malheureusement depuis trop longtemps
mais qui aujourd'hui s'accentue pourquoi
passionnés policiers de terrain ceux qui
sont soumis à des contraintes je dirais
effréné lié à la menace terroriste mais
pas qu'à la menace terroriste
aujourd'hui ne comprennent pas comment
se fait ce qu'il ait fallu je dirais
l'article et la vidéo publiée par le
monde pour qu'apparaissent les
agissements ô combien puni serbe est
condamnable de cet individu
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui la les gardiens
de la paix se pose des questions se
posent des questions sur ce qui a pu se
passer en amont se pose des questions
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer à
plusieurs reprises dans les médias
et aujourd'hui on parle on a
l'impression aujourd'hui d'être
confrontés une police parallèle dit et
par certains et je n'ai même employer un
mot très fort mais que dont j'assume la
complète responsabilité à savoir est ce
que nous étions confronté ni plus ni
moins qu'à des barbouzes alors les
policiers aujourd'hui sont en attente de
décision les policiers n'ont pas très
bien compris non plus je dirais l'ailé
les passages de témoins qui ont eu effet
entre les responsables de la préfecture
de police de paris entre autres
aujourd'hui on a du mal à comprendre
nous gardiens de la paix on a du mal à
comprendre comment la haute hiérarchie
policière de la préfecture de police
n'était pas au courant des agissements
de monsieur benalla et de quelques-uns
de ses comparses
voilà en quelques mots l'aider je pense
avoir suffisamment résumé avoir été
suffisamment concis pour pouvoir vous
donner l'état d'esprit aujourd'hui des
policiers que nous représentons
je vais simplement vous demandez quel
écho vous avez des relations de vos
collègues avec monsieur benalla je vais
vous demander aussi puisque
théoriquement je dis bien théoriquement
il n'existe pas de chaîne de
commandement entre monsieur benalla et
les personnels de la police ou de la
gendarmerie nationales qui sont sous
l'autorité du ministère de l'intérieur
et des oeufs de la hiérarchie de la
police et de la gendarmerie
et il arrivait que certaines certains de
vos collègues soit amené à s'opposer ou
à ne pas prendre en compte certaines
incitations pour parler de manière
modérée de monsieur ban à la voyez ce
que je veux dire
et ne vous paraît-il ne vous paraître
est il pas souhaitable qu'il eut un
statut clairement définis pour ce qui
est de la protection du président de la
république et des hautes personnalités
qui prévoirait que cela relève
exclusivement de la notorité des
personnes compétentes et formé de la
police et de la gendarmerie nationale
général
alors ce qui concerne les relations de
monsieur benalla avec mes collègues du
groupe de sécurité du président la
république du gspr qui relève du service
de protection des hautes personnalités
il ya une alternance en fonction du
président parfois ce sont nos collègues
gendarmes parfois ce sont nos collègues
policiers qui assurent cette protection
depuis la fin de semaine dernière les
langues commencent à se délier
manifestations mais manifestement pardon
monsieur bénard a faisait régner la
terreur au sein du gspr monsieur benalla
n'hésitait pas d'après les propos qui
nous sont rapportées bien évidemment
nous n'étions pas témoin de ces propos
ni de ses agissements mais semblerait
manifestement que cette personne allait
jusqu'à l'insultent à l'encontre des
gradés et gardiens de la paix avant même
peut-être des officiers constituant ce
groupe
aujourd'hui il est bien évidemment pour
répondre à votre question il n'est pas
question aujourd'hui qu'un policier
puisse à avoir à obéir à une personne
qui ne relèvent pas de la hiérarchie
policière
c'est complètement inconcevable bien
évidemment il ya le le statut du corps
préfectoral
mais ça on est dans un autre domaine
parce qu'en l'occurrence jamais un
préfet ne se permet d'ordonner un
policier sauf en passant bien évidemment
par sa hiérarchie directe mais là on est
vraiment dans un système pour le moins
opaque d'une personne qui a tenté
notamment
là encore les langues se délient d'avoir
une intimidation constante et récurrente
et d'avoir tenté de réformer le système
de sécurité du gspr notamment pour le
fort de brégançon
ces dernières semaines mon organisation
syndicale n'a jamais été associé à ce
débat je sais qu'il a tenté de le faire
et pour le coup effectivement une
organisation syndicale autre que la
nôtre s'est opposé légitimement à cette
tentative je dirais de restructuration
mais là on était vraiment sur une
personne qui qui jouait de sa relation
après le système pourrait-on dire
comment se fait-il que des policiers
puissent accepter d ordre d instruction
accepter autant peut-être de quolibets
sinon même d' insulte la problème
la problématique se fonde sur le fait
que nous sommes inclus dans une chaîne
et hiérarchique aussi et que cette
personne avait quand même le statut de
chef de cabinet adjoint de l'élysée et
faisait régner la terreur à travers son
statut tout simplement vous savez quand
eu un gardien de la paix un gradé un
officier voire même certainement un
commissaire en face de lui une personne
disant j'ai le une relation directe
constante et récurrente avec le
président de la république
peu d'entre nous sauf peut-être les
syndicalistes ce dont je suis convaincu
ailleurs au demeurant mais un
fonctionnaire de police et son show
péjoratif lambda ne s'opposera que très
rarement
il a l'oeil l'incarnait à travers ses
propos son attitude une je dirais une
posture de pouvoir suprême
il faisait part le fait régner la
terreur selon les éléments en ma
possession
il semblerait manifestement qu'au sein
du gsp un jean sisto bien sûr le
semblerait avec le conditionnel qui
s'imposent qu'effectivement au sein du
j'espère nous avions un groupe un groupe
de deux de personnel or police et or
jean namory dans hors du champ de la
mission régalienne de sécurité qui doit
être celle du gsp à la protection du
président avec lui et de son épouse qui
en l'occurrence était d'aider des civils
des privés et c'est bien pour ça que
j'ai employé depuis le début depuis
jeudi dernier jean pas le terme de
barbouzes parce que ces gens là n'ont
une habilitation
ce ne sont ni plus ni moins que sans que
ce soit péjoratif j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les métiers de la sécurité
privée
mais ce sont des vigiles qui était
employé aujourd'hui manifestement par
monsieur benalla dans le cadre de la
protection de la présidence de la
république
oui effectivement monsieur le secrétaire
général cette information que vous nous
donnez est extrêmement importante est ce
que vous êtes en mesure de la source et
je vais la source et moi j'ai les
renseignements que j'ai c'est bien
évidemment à travers nos réseaux de
délégués au sein du service de
protection des hautes personnalités du
sphp et bien évidemment par part est
fait je dirais sur le gspr les éléments
que j'ai eus m'ont été rapportés
effectivement par mes représentants
locaux qui m'ont dit effectivement qui
m'ont affirmé qu'ils avaient des groupes
de 2,2 privé qu'il travaillait en
l'occurrence avec monsieur benalla et
qui est provoqué justement détention
avéré entre eux les fonctions de police
et monsieur b nana et ses comparses qui
en l'occurrence et ça serait d'ailleurs
un délai de motifs de la réorganisation
du gspr dans la perspective de la
protection du fort de brégançon pendant
les vacances du président monsieur le
secrétaire général est ce que vos
correspondants vous vous aurez indiqué
le nombre de vigiles qui n'en revenais
pas je n'ai pas nombre et si monsieur le
président mais on peut s'en enquérir et
je ne manquerai pas de porter à votre
connaissance si vous me le permettez de
tels renseignements et je ne vous le
permet pas je vous le demande
il a reçu monsieur le président j'ai
voulu nécessaires à la collecte de
renseignements sont à mais sans délai je
vous remercie et vous avez peut-être
d'autres 6e nous apporter non passer par
ce domaine
voilà madame j'entends un madame
eustache brinio et je pose à sa place la
question depuis quand le savez vous
éprouvez vous pourrez vous nous
l'indiqué aussi je pourrais je pourrais
je pourrais vous l'indiquez
effectivement les langues se délient
parce que vous comprenez aisément que
quand on a essayé d'avoir des
renseignements le week-end dernier il y
avait je dirais une chape de plomb est
quelque peu d'aidé refus de répondre à
nos sollicitations la matière ce qui se
comprend aisément depuis les
fonctionnaires qui sont affectés aux
j'espère qu'ils ont un devoir de réserve
en l'état seuls les représentants du
personnel pourront s'enquérir de la
chose et on essaiera d'avoir le maximum
de renseignements pour que l'on puisse
apporter des éléments nécessaires à
l'enquêté
messieurs vous voulez apporter des
précisions mais simplement apporter une
précision mais qui est qui doit être
évidente à mon sens pour tout le monde
sait que compte tenu de la sensibilité
de cette affaire et de l'endroit où
était affecté entre guillemets monsieur
benalla c'est à dire il peut du moins
dans la proximité du président de la
république il arborait systématiquement
sa carte
à n'importe quel fonctionnaire qui est
rencontraient du cabinet donc de
l'elysée il est bien évident que faire
parler nos collègues et je répond
directement à la question précédemment
que ce soit les gars des gradés et
gardiens de la paix mais aussi de la
moyenne est rare chez les officiers et
les commissaires personne n'allait se
répandre sur des travers qui aurait pu
être effectués et semble-t-il puisque le
secrétaire général vient d'annoncer qu
effectivement les langues se délient on
apprend qu'il ya eu plusieurs quoi
qu'ils n'étaient pas de même niveau
certes mais qui à la fois faisait état
d' altercation avec les forces de police
et de gendarmerie sur certains maintien
de l'ordre
roux il souhaitait prendre la tête du
dispositif ou détourné l'action de la
police nationale sur certaines
interventions et qui plus est pour ceux
qui éventuellement pouvait trouver ça
totalement anormal et éventuellement le
faire savoir
et bien il y avait effectivement cette
carte qu'il présentait qu'il arborait
que là pour le coup c'était plus
difficile à faire savoir au garrot
déroulement carrière que vous pouvez
bien comprendre c'est chaud mais que
c'est très important ce que veut dire je
vous en remercie mais cela appelle de ma
part une question complémentaire
quelques couacs pouvez vous les décrire
alors effectivement il a été porté à
notre connaissance mais on pourra amener
des précisions encore plus clair d après
c'est que assez régulièrement la
présence de monsieur benalla sur des
manifestations où il était forcément
autorise à yale et sur ces
manifestations et bien systématiquement
il il essayait de prendre la main sur le
dispositif y compris auprès de hauts
gradés et certains de nos collègues non
nous donne nos représentants ont pu
confirmer qu'il y avait eu des tensions
et où il a été écarté par le fait qu' il
souhaitait intervenir ou décider de
telle ou telle manipulation des
effectifs
donc vous voulez dire que l'autorité de
police s'est refusée à ce moment-là à
déférer à ses ordres à ses instructions
à ses recommandations wii ou à sa
volonté d agir autrement
très bien je vous remercie madame
benbassa brune ultime question nous
avons juste merci monsieur le président
une toute petite question pourquoi
pourquoi cette sécurité privée qui prend
la place de la police aux halles elysées
mais quel est l'objectif pourquoi cette
sécurité privées ces personnes que vous
appelez des barbouzes à côté de la
police qui l'emplît seo j'espère l'aca
fonctions de sécurité du président merci
je suis président je reprends je
reprends dessus de réponses à tes son
drame vous savez madame la sénatrice
très franchement je crois que c'est au
présent dans la pluie qui vous pose la
question en la matière sinon monsieur
avait un monsieur benalla pourquoi ou
sans doute à monsieur le directeur
cabinet de l'elysée nous pour ça on ne
rompt ne sait pas on apprend ces choses
petit au fur et à mesure voilà talent
une question m'a été posée depuis quand
je connais monsieur benalla très
simplement j'ai été reçu par président
de la république à la fin du mois de
janvier dans le cadre des changes bien
évidemment dans le cadre du dialogue
social qui s'imposaient prison n'avait
plus il voulait s'enquérir de l'état des
des forces de sécurité
deux républiques notre belle république
et j'ai croisés dans un établissement
public j'ai croisé cette personne sans
savoir qui c'était c'est quand j'ai vu
ces photos à paraître dans tous les
médias de france ils ont même du monde
entier mercredi et jeudi que je me suis
remémoré avoir vu cette personne qui
n'avait de cesse déjà les potes de
parler de 2 de son étui pour son arme et
pour moi et mon collègue qui étaient
présents ce jour là pour nous il
s'agissait d'un collègue policier du
gspr
ils avaient tous les latitudes et preuve
en est faite ils avaient tous les
attributs et je vous fais grâce de la
voiture c'était en journée c'était un
lundi matin de très bonne heure dans un
bar pas très éloigné à mi chemin entre
entre beau vos analyses et madame voyez
vous voyez alors s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît il faut qu alors qu'il y ait
ici aussi une certaine police de notre
commission et le rôle ingrat que
j'accepte d'assumer ses de l'exercer
mais je le fais à titre officiel alors
monsieur le secrétaire général vous
voulez ajouter quelque chose mais moi je
vais vous rappeler aussi qu'il nous veut
qu'il vous faut répondre à la question
de madame marie mercier tout à l'heure à
laquelle vous n'avez pas répondu qui
vous a demandé si dans votre expérience
de policiers vous avez déjà rencontré ce
type d' usurpation d'autorité venant
d'un collaborateur de la présidence de
la république voilà alors je vous laisse
reprendre la parole n'ont jamais non
jamais j'ai 36 ans de police nationale
derrière moi j'ai beaucoup de maintien
de l'ordre
je n'ai jamais été confronté à ce genre
d'agissements jamais jamais jamais dieu
jamais il ya aussi une question monsieur
le président si une vérité sur le sur le
l'âge 26 ans 26 ans 26 ans vous savez
éviter gp police force ouvrière n'a de
cesse de lutter syndicalement parlant
pour permettre à nos collègues d'obtenir
le grade supérieur légitimes attentes
légitimes attentes
aujourd'hui pour accéder au grade de
brigadier-chef qui ont en hébreu gadier
sur moyenne 15 à 20 ans
et il faut surtout pas être bancaire de
police dans la creuse dans les landes
au pays basque où dans le morbihan parce
que là ça sera 35 ou 40 ans sinon même
dans les antilles d'envoyer c'est pour
nous c'est proprement parler scandaleux
comment cet individu a 26 ans et puis
est nommé lieutenant colonel en retour
en ça c'est véritablement une insulte à
nos camarades d'armes que sont nos
collègues gendarmes
donc c'est une insulte effectivement on
peut faire valoir le côté expertise mais
passez moi du peu l' expertise en la
matière est complètement irrecevable sur
la la question enfin je dirais la lame
la mise en avant par les avocats de
monsieur benalla du fait que nos
collègues crs étaient débordés le
premier mais je suis intervenu à
plusieurs reprises dans les médias en
disant que le premier mais même si ça a
peut-être tarder un peu l'intervention
devant le mcdonald's et devant la
concession au tour à hauteur du pont
d'austerlitz j'ai considéré à l'époque
que les effectifs étaient largement
dimensionnés on n'était pas en sous
dimensionnement on était largement bien
dimensionné et qu'en l'occurrence dans
un tel cas il valait mieux attendre
malheureusement valait mieux je dirais
constaté des dégâts matériels que
d'avoir concédé des dégâts humains donc
en aucun cas les crs n'ont été en
position d'être débordés même sur cette
place le 1er mai absolument pas je ne
complète maîtrise la situation
les crs sont des professionnels reconnus
dans le monde entier en matière de
gestion du maintien de l'ordre mais
petit d'heures que les gendarmes mobiles
parce qu'il faut associer nos
collections d'armes en la matière lors
il n'y a jamais été question de
débordement le fait de devoir à tout
prix saisir au vu d'un article du code
de procédure pénale faire saisir ces
c'est une infraction
franchement franchement c'est fait à
l'eau de rose s'est indûment terre
passez moi l'expression de secrétaire
général et monsieur le secrétaire
général délégué je tiens vous remercier
et de la franchise et du courage de
votre expression devant la commission
des lois du sénat
c'est bien ce que nous attendions de
vous je connais monsieur benalla pour
l'avoir croisé depuis ma prise de
fonction le 28 août dernier lors de
déplacements ou de cérémonies auxquelles
participait le président de la
république et auquel j'étais convié jeu
l'identifier clairement comme un
collaborateur du chef de cabinet
résidence de la république dont l'une
des missions centrale habituelle d'un
cabinet est d'organiser ses déplacements
ou ces cérémonies officielles
il était donc tout à fait naturel qu'ils
soient présents dans ces circonstances
une dizaine de fois pour ce qui me
concerne la dernière dans la tribune
officielle du 14 juillet au cours de
kate desquels je n'ai jamais remarqué de
sa part une attitude déplacée ou qu'ils
me soient apparus intrusive
je n'ai jamais eu à échanger avec lui
d'autres propos que de courtoise
salutations je n'ai pas le souvenir
d'avoir participé à des réunions travail
en sa présence
il faut dire que mes contacts avec la
présidence de la république sont rares
ces relations étant normalement réservé
au cabinet du ministre qui au besoin me
sollicite lorsque des commandes
techniques sont exprimées par la
présidence en ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement les événements de la
place de la contrescarpe du 1er mai il
m'apparaît important de vous décrire
rapidement l'organisation des opérations
de maintien de l'ordre en france sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
à paris comme ailleurs le préfet
territorialement compétent à la pleine
responsabilité de la gestion de l'ordre
public
c'est sous son autorité que sont
organisées les dispositifs opérationnels
qui seront mis en oeuvre sur le terrain
par les forces de police ou de
gendarmerie parfois combinées
mon rôle consiste mon rôle de directeur
général de la police nationale consiste
donc à fournir aux préfets préfets de
police compris les forces mobiles
nécessaires au service d'ordre qu'il
prévoit selon les renseignements dont je
dispose sur le contexte de l'événement à
gérer et en fonction des forces
disponibles qu'elles appartiennent à la
police les crs ou à la gendarmerie
nationale des escadrons de gendarmerie
mobile pour le 1er mai ce sont 15 forces
mobiles de la réserve nationale dix crs
et cinq escadrons de gendarmerie mobile
que j'ai mis à disposition du préfet de
police
s'ajoutant aux huit crs qui constitue l'
enveloppe parisienne permanente dont il
dispose soit un total de 23 unités
s'ajoutant elle même aux forces
territoriale de la préfecture
au terme des opérations les services de
police transmettent à mon état major un
compte rendu synthétique décrivant leur
rouler le bilan blessure interpellation
dégâts éventuels incidents
s'agissant du 1er mai le télégramme de
la crs numéro 15 présente sur la place
de la contrescarpe qui est une crs basée
à béthune rapporte les événements graves
auxquels ces fonctionnaires ont été
confrontés pendant toute la durée de
leur vacation commencé à 12h40 et
terminer à 23 heures sans mentionner de
faits impliquant des observateurs
rétrospectivement une ligne de ce
télégramme de compte rendu fait sans
doute référence aux événements qui
motive la formation de des commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires en cours
elle est ainsi libellé 20h15
deux individus interpellés violence
contre agent de la force publique remis
à la brigade d'information de voie
publique
au-delà de cette information
opérationnel transmises par les services
de police eux mêmes à mon état major je
peux être rendue également destinataire
par les préfets ou par les directions
centrales placé sous mon autorité
d'informations sur le comportement
inadapté voire fautif d'une unité d'un
ou de plusieurs fonctionnaires sur la
base d'éléments circonstancié et
vérifier que je déclenche alors une
procédure disciplinaire en saisissant en
saisissant par dont l'inspection
générale de la police nationale avec
mesure de suspension le cas échéant et
cela indépendamment des poursuites
judiciaires éventuelles décidée par le
parquet compétent
au terme des événements du 1er mai aucun
signalement de ce type n'a été porté à
ma connaissance aucun incident dans la
conduite des opérations ne m'a été
révélé
je n'ai été informé des agissements
répréhensibles de monsieur benalla qu'à
l'occasion de la publication du journal
le monde daté du 18 juillet
al'inverse le 19 juillet les agissements
résumé délictuelle de trois
fonctionnaires de la démo pc qui ont
participé à l'extraction des images de
vidéo protection publique et à leur
communication à monsieur benalla m'ont
été signalée immédiatement compte tenu
de la gravité des faits avec la
circonstance particulière qu'ils avaient
été commis par des cadres des hauts
cadres de la police nationale qui ne
pouvait ignorer qu'ils commettaient
siham en une infraction
j'ai donc donné instruction à mes
services avant même les décisions de
l'autorité judiciaire de prendre sans
délai les actes de suspension j'ai
également demandé au préfet de police de
saisir l'igpn défunt décide
disciplinaire ce qu'il a fait il nous
reviendra in fine et car c'est ma seule
compétence de prendre les sanctions qui
s'imposent rang au terme des procédures
disciplinaires qui vont se dérouler les
sanctions sont en général signée par mon
délégataire le directeur des ressources
et des compétences de la police
nationale à l'exception des révocations
dont je me réserve l'exclusivité des
signatures compte tenu de la gravité de
la mesure pour être complet et j'en
finirai par là je précise que l'igpn
avait été rendu destinataire vous
entendrez je crois me l'a mené j'ai tout
à l'heure pour être compétent je précise
donc que l'igpn avait été rendu
destinataire sur sa plate forme de
signalement en ligne d'image de la scène
de la contrescarpe ces images avaient
été postées le 3 mai à 2h13 par un
internaute sous pseudo ne permettant pas
d'identifier ne se présentant pas comme
protagonistes de la scène filmée mais
indiquant simplement l'avoir trouvée sur
les réseaux sociaux
l'inspection générale dans mes
circonstances particulières de ce
signalement en l'absence de plainte et
dans le contexte des grandes violences
subies par les forces de l'ordre lors de
ces manifestations du prime du 1er mai
n'a pas considéré pertinent de
déclencher des investigations je dois
préciser que les images postées était
prise sous un angle qui ne mettait pas
en évidence des violences avérées l'igpn
a considéré légitime au vu de ces images
l' usage de la force appliquée
l'inspection ne disposait alors que de
ses seules images et non celle qui
depuis ont été diffusées largement prise
sous différents angles par différents
opérateurs qui sont aujourd'hui à notre
disposition mais dont ne disposaient pas
dit j'ai peine dans cette fameuse nuit
du 3 mai à 2h13 ces images celles qui
ont été déposés sur la plateforme en
ligne ont toutefois été conservé au cas
où une plainte serait ultérieurement
déposer ou un signalement exploitables
postés on sait aujourd'hui que ça n'a
pas été le cas
l'igpn ne m'a pas tenu informé de ce
signalement ce que l'on considère
parfaitement normal dans l'état de
connaissance des faits qui était le sien
à ce moment là la chef de l'inspection
madame monéger que je rencontre très
régulièrement ne manque jamais de me
rendre compte des faits graves qui sont
portés à sa connaissance étaient des
hits des diligences qu'elle entreprend
en toute indépendance et je dois le
souligner sans aucune faiblesse
mais la gravité de la scène que j'évoque
ne sera établi que bien plus tard
lorsque l'illégitimité des
interpellateurs entre guillemets sera
révélé à l'igpn comme à moi même par
l'article du monde et teyran le sujet
d'un jour tout à fait nouveau et
caractérisant des infractions que
l'autorité judiciaire vient de qualifiés
pénalement
je me tiens monsieur le président madame
monsieur les pourra porter à votre
disposition et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs pour répondre à vos questions
et vous apporter toutes précisions
utiles à vos travaux qu'il s'agisse de
l'accueil des observateurs de la sphère
benalla dans le respect des
investigations judiciaires en cours et
dans les limites de ce que j'en connais
ou plus généralement de l'organisation
de mes services en matière de protection
des hautes personnalités
les faits remontent au 1er mai la
ministre de l'intérieur le préfet de
police le directeur de cabinet du
ministre l'intérieur le directeur du
cabinet du président de la république
sont tous au courant des faits le 2 mai
vous n'êtes saisi que récemment après
que
la sphère benalla soit devenue publique
cette saisine est manifestement légitime
compte tenu de toutes les questions que
vous avez à examiner est il normal d'un
point de vue de bon fonctionnement de
l'administration qu' il ait fallu
attendre cette affaire reçoivent toute
la publicité qu'elle a reçue pour que
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale est à se pencher sur elle en
tant que chef d'une inspection générale
je ne peux me raccrocher qu'aux textes
et l'article 40 du code de procédure
pénale et éclaire toute personne ayant
connu un délit voilà puisque vous le
connaissez par coeur je ne vais pas vous
faire l'injure de le leur dire d'autant
que je n'ai pas sous les yeux et je
risquerais d'être d'être imprécises
pouvait
saisir l'inspection générale ou faire ou
faire une une déclaration propre record
la république puisque l'on ferait que je
vous remercie madame le rapporteur merci
monsieur président madame la directrice
une question un peu similaire mais
formuler quelque peu différemment vous
recevez donc cette vidéo vos services
reçoivent cette vidéo début mais en
ignorant l'auteur des faits il estime
que s'il s'agit de policiers il n'est
pas de motif pour poursuivre plus avant
en recevant cette vidéo et connaissant
l'auteur des faits c'est à dire le fait
que ce soit un observateur quelle aurait
été la marche à suivre pour vos services
[Musique]
si nous avions su que
les deux personnes en cause n'était pas
fonctionnaire de police
nous aurions démarré une enquête
judiciaire après avoir rendu compte bien
sûr au parquet et nous aurions doubler
cette enquête judiciaire par une enquête
administrative mais enquête
administrative qui nous pouvait pour le
coup un pacte et que les fonctionnaires
de police puisque l'inspection générale
est compétente que pour les
fonctionnaires de police
je vous remercie madame le rapporteur
d'autres questions le rapporteur il y a
quelque chose de singulier dans le fait
que un grand nom un certain nombre de
personnes
le ministre de l'intérieur le préfet de
police le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république soit au
courant dès le 2 mai défait par une
vidéo sur laquelle apparaît monsieur
bénalia et que ni la direction générale
de la police nationale ni l'inspection
générale auprès de la foule que la
police nationale ne soit au courant
il ya quelque chose d'étonnant en
quelque sorte
d'autre part vous ne pouvez pas ne pas
ignorer me semble-t-il ou peut être
l'avez vous ignorez vous nous le dire
est que monsieur bénalia a été mise à
pied
je suppose que vous vous en êtes rendu
compte
et après vous avez sans doute entendu
puisque ces pubs louis saha était dit
publiquement qu'il a été démis de ses
fonctions en matière de sécurité et vous
n'avez pas pu ne pas voir qu'alors qu'il
était démis de ses fonctions dixit le
porte parole de l'elysée il était
présent dans les mêmes fonctions de
sécurité de protection que ce soit au
panthéon pour l'arrivée des cendres de
simone veil que ce soit même dans la
tribune officielle du 14 juillet enfin
avez-vous eu une réflexion sur ce qui
s'est passé le 1er mai et sur l'attitude
des forces de police puisqu'il nous a
été dit que les crs en particulier était
resté statique pour des raisons qui
tiennent aux instructions qu'ils ont
reçues
donc c'est très clair mais lorsqu il y à
des policiers qui sont là et qui lie à
des personnes qui ne sont pas policiers
b observateurs qui mène une action qui
comportent un degré de violence
il ya quand même quelques questions que
l'on peut légitimement se poser
voilà mes interrogations madame la
directrice vous avez la parole madame
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur je ne connais pas monsieur
benalla mon adjoint ne connaît pas
monsieur benalla et je n'ai aucune
raison de participer à quelques réunions
que ce soir avec
avec les services de l'elysée qui sont
en contact avec les services
opérationnels l'inspection générale
n'est pas un service opérationnel qui
est sur le terrain c'est un service à
part et donc il n'y a aucune raison de
connaître monsieur benalla et de
participer à quelques réunions que ce
soit et donc il n'y a aucune raison non
plus pour les et de rendre compte à
l'igpn de la suspension d'un contractuel
et aucune raison enfin j'veux dire je
n'ai aucun moyen d'aller vérifier tout
ça donc pour la première partie de votre
question la réponse est non nous
n'avions aucune
enfin aucune raison de pouvoir vérifier
aucun des points que vous avez évoqué en
ce qui concerne votre deuxième question
c'est à dire l'attitude des forces de
police ce que j'ai pu observer c'est
qu'il y avait effectivement des crs donc
en uniforme et en unités constituées sur
sur les lieux et qu' il y avait des
personnes en civil portant des signes
distinctifs police ça n'est pas choquant
pour moi puisque je sais que lors de
maintien de l'ordre
il est habituel d'avoir des unités
constituées et des unités en civil qui
interviennent notamment pour faire un
certain nombre d'interpellations et pour
mettre à disposition des officiers de
police judiciaire des fauteurs de
trouble donc ce mélange des unités en
civil et en et en tenue n'est pas n'est
pas un n'est pas né n'est pas une
surprise pour pour nous
voilà ce que
on observe également c'est que les
unités constituées bien elles répondent
à des ad comment dire à des ordres qui
sont données par le chef de service qui
va pouvoir un moment donné utilise dire
par exemple utilisation de la force
interpellations et cetera et cetera
ça ça n'est pas du tout un problème pour
moi
et lorsque nous visionnons ces images
pour dire les choses très clairement la
seule chose qu'on observe c'est que les
gestes techniques d'intervention sont
pas très bien maîtrisé et pour cause et
pour cause donc les les agents de l'igpn
qui kills qui voit les images le note
d'ailleurs le note d'ailleurs pas de
violences illégitimes en forme en gros
les tpe sont assez mal maîtrisée bien
mais ça c'est l'oeil du spécialiste qui
le voient c'est l'oeil de l'agent de
l'igpn qui est lui-même fonctionnaires
de police et qui connaît les gt pays les
gestes techniques d'intervention et qui
peut porter cette cette appréciation
pour autant encore une fois le sujet ça
n'est pas l'illégitimité de l'emploi de
la force
c'est le sujet de qui est ce qu'ils sont
sur la place
l'enquète le dira avait-il conscience
qu'ils avaient des observateurs ou
pensait-il avoir des collègues à côté
d'eux est en tout cas ceux qui observent
la vidéo le 5 ou le 6 mai eh bien ils
n'ont pas du tout enfin ils n'ont pas de
doute sur le fait que ce sont des
policiers qui sont sur la place et est
ce que si monsieur le prestataire me
permets unifie le demande
il y a sur place forcément un
responsable une personne ayant autorité
de la police nationale de cette personne
c'est que le statut des deux personnes
qui interviennent est un statut
d'observateur je suppose réagit-il ne
réagit-il pas et rend-il compte alors
allez-y
oui merci du président
tout ça ce sont des éléments de
précision qui font partie de l' enquête
judiciaire
donc vous comprendrez que je ne peux pas
en parler aujourd'hui mais évidemment ce
sont des questions qui se posent le chef
du service d'ordre savait-il que
monsieur benalla et monsieur kraz
était-il là at il les moyens de faire la
différence et at il vu at il observé
et
qu'at-il fait ce sont évidemment des
questions très pertinentes qu'il nous
appartiendra de poser aussi bien dans l'
enquête judiciaire que dans la quête
administrative merci madame madame
jourda
vous n'avez plus de questions alors nous
allons maintenant entendre nos collègues
ils vont chacun posez une question en
moins d'une minute c'est d'abord
monsieur collombat merci monsieur le
président madame monsieur oui depuis que
nous avons commencé cette cette
commission en fait on a eu en gros deux
types de réponses on n'était pas
informée c'est pas mon domaine de
compétence
alors on l a redit ses domaines de
compétence de qui des phénomènes aussi
quand même caractérisé enfin aussi
déplorable alors moi je ma question
porterait sur vos toi est-ce que vous
avez une possibilité légale de vous auto
saisine de vous saisir donc de fait qui
vous paraître qui vous paraissent sinon
encore délictueux du mois méritait un
examen un examen attentif parce que je
vous avoue que dans ce que vous nous
avez dit mais peut-être que j'ai mal
interprété c'est pas vraiment il me
semble qu'il ya une espèce de
contradiction ou vite
s'agissant des événements tels qu'ils
apparaissent par la première dans la
première vidéo ça a l'air d'être une
opération de police de police ordinaire
maintien de l'ordre etc
si je ne pars facile donc très bien oui
merci encore aux coups de pied près
quand même pas des gestes techniques
un record aux commandes allez madame
d'après vous il est terminé merci
beaucoup ont fait vous nous dites pas
non à une fois qu'on a su qu'ils
s'étaient alors vous avez été saisies
mais on peut pas intervenir parce que
c'est pas un personnel de police bon
allez madame madame la directrice de
manière très concise votre réponse je
vais essayer d'être concise
je suis d'accord avec vous sur la
première partie effectivement lorsqu'on
regarde la vidéo elle n'est pas elle
n'est pas pour nous constitutive d'une
infraction de manquement le vrai sujet
c'est que cet usage de la force
s'il est légitime de la part de
fonctionnaires de police devient
illégitime
si ça n'est pas un fonctionnaire de
police qui qui qui agissent à partir de
ce moment là effectivement il y a
ouverture d'une enquête judiciaire sous
la soul a sous la direction du parquet
et ouverture d'une enquête
administrative
et c'est effectivement ce que fait le
gpn dès lors qu'elle sait que
l'intervention n'a pas été le fait de
fonctionnaires de police elle ouvre ces
deux enquêtes l'une à la demande du
parquet et l'autre à la demande et
l'autre pardon automatiquement
puisqu'elle peut se saisir dans cette
enquête administrative
nous pourrons entendre éventuellement
proposé que soient déférés devant les
autorités disciplinaires les
fonctionnaires de police par les autres
pas les autres les gpm les textes là
aussi sont très claires ah bah bien sûr
qu'on va éclairer le paysage et dans l'
enquête administrative dans l' enquête
administrative
on pourra entendre toute personne qui
voudrait extérieurs à la police qui
voudra bien déféré à notre convocation
un fonctionnaire de police ne pourra pas
dire j'ai pas envie de parler à
l'inspection générale
mais quelqu'un d'extérieur à la police
pourra dire je n'ai pas envie de parler
à l'inspection générale donc encore une
fois que les choses soient très claires
enquête judiciaire d'un côté enquête
administrative de l'autre pouvant
conclure à des propositions de sanctions
disciplinaires mais enquête
administrative pour en pouvant conclure
à des sanctions disciplinaires
uniquement pour les fonctionnaires de
paix
vous savez vous l'avez dit qu'une vidéo
a été tournée à l'occasion des
manifestations du 1er mai qui a été mis
sur les réseaux sociaux très rapidement
dès le 2 mai est tout aussi rapidement a
été identifié sur cette vidéo
une personne qui interpellait des
individus au cours d'une manifestation
cette personne se révélant être un
observateur
monsieur b dallas pour le site et qui
donc intervenait au milieu des forces de
police dans le cadre d'une
interpellation que d'aucuns ont pu
qualifier d' un peu rugueuse et ne
maîtrisant pas ça aussi ça a été établie
vous l'avez rappelé des gestes
techniques de l'interpellation
cela a été révélé assez rapidement
notamment au ministère de l'intérieur
qu'il a su dès le 2 mai et qui donc
s'est rendu compte qu'il s'agissait d'un
observateur qui avait probablement mais
on ne le savait pas exactement quand on
connaissait pas les conditions échapper
à son référent puisque un observateur
même si les règles n'existent pas et
toujours dans la pratique accompagnée
d'un référent policiers qui est à la
fois chargé de sa protection mais aussi
de vérifier qu'il n'ya pas de
comportement inapproprié
donc nous sommes dans cette situation
connue dès le 2 mai du ministère de
l'intérieur
le ministre de l'intérieur ne saisit pas
l'igpn pour connaître notamment les
circonstances de ces actes le 18 juillet
une nouvelle vidéo et médiatiser cette
vidéo concerne la même personne mais en
des circonstances un peu différente
de sorte qu apparaissent à l'écran des
éléments qui n'apparaissait pas à savoir
le fait que cet observateur monsieur b
dallas portaient un brassard de police
et avait également une radio sur
laquelle ils conversaient hélas le
ministère de l'intérieur saisi l'igpn
nous disons et c'est monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur qu'il a dit au
cours de son audition que le fait qu'on
découvre désormais le brassard de police
et la radio étaient des éléments
suffisants pour justifier la saisine de
l'igpn
ma question est la suivante estimez-vous
au regard de ces éléments que l'igpn
aurait dû être saisie
dès le visionnage de la première vidéo
de l'interpellation le 2 mai je veux
dire monsieur le défenseur des droits
quand vous avez la parole bien sûr pour
répondre à cette question j'ajoute une
petite précision
c'est ces délais ces délais ont fait
involontairement que les vidéos
la plupart des vidéos devait avoir
disparu puisque nous allons dépasser le
délai de 30 jours et que l'ensemble des
enregistrements qui ont pu être faits
par le réseau acropole ont disparu
puisque nous sommes après le délai de 60
jours
[Musique]
madame le rapporteur quant à la saisine
de l'igpn
après la connaissance qu'on a eu des
événements et des personnes impliquées
dans ces événements par les vidéos je
distinguerai une saisine de l'igpn qui
serait ça s'appelle comme ça pour faire
une enquête administrative purement
administrative à ce moment là elle
pouvait porter sur les personnes qui
peuvent faire l'objet d'une enquête mise
sur pied c'est à dire les policiers mais
elle ne pouvait pas porter sur les
personnes qui n'étaient pas des
policiers
et en l'occurrence sur les deux
observateurs
première réponse donc je dirais une
ouverture de l' enquête administrative
relativement étroite ensuite ouverture
d'une enquête judiciaire dont les gipn a
le pouvoir le pouvoir de faire là dessus
cette ouverture pouvait être justifiée
par la violence les excès eux-mêmes qui
pouvait naturellement
être considéré comme constitutif
éventuellement d'infractions pénales
sur ce point j'ai observé que la
directrice de l'inspection générale ce
matin lorsque vous l'avez entendu a
justement expliqué que cela n'ait pas
été fait parce que la force qui avait
été employé les gestes qu'ils avaient
été faits avaient été considérés comme
proportionnée en quelque sorte oui ou
non violent ou pas suffisamment violent
pour entraîner 7e l'ouverture de cette
enquête
et c'est un peu à partir de cette
réflexion qui a été faite ce matin par
bada monéger du sorbet que je vous ai
posé tout à l'heure la question de
légitimité intensité d usage de la force
par les forces de sécurité est une
question qui mérite d'être posée
suivant les points de vue que l'on a
donc sur l' enquête administrative comme
sur l' enquête judiciaire
voilà le positionnement de la question
et je vous ai dit tout à l'heure je veux
dit tout à l'heure que de mon point de
vue la question pouvait vraiment se
poser au moment des faits puisque j'ai
bien parlé de du 2 mai d'ouvrir en tout
cas eu une enquête judiciaire
mais je me garderai bien madame le
rapporteur de vous donner là dessus une
opinion du défenseur des droits
parce que je n'ai naturellement aucun
titre le faire mais ça fait partie des
questions qui méritent d'être posées
nous avons évoqué monsieur vinolas et et
son grade du togo certes qui est
provisoire et c'est un petit peu un
petit peu symbolique première question y
at il quelque une autre personne est
clair
obtenu hockey à laquelle a été octroyé
ce titre à l'âge de 26 ans ou avant
première chose deuxième chose lorsque
l'on en croit ce grade
vous avez dit qu'il n'y avait pas de
commission de ça est ce qu'on a vérifié
ses antécédents de horse ce dont ils se
prévalent et c'est à dire un master de
droit
et puis est-ce qu'on a vérifié son
casier sont quasi judiciaire et ses
antécédents en général merci pour pour
ces questions alors ses antécédents ont
été vérifiés dans le cadre de sa son
recrutement en tant que réservistes
opérationnels en 2009 c'est à dire que
quand on engage un réserviste il ya un
passage officier comme on dire
on vérifie effectivement qui est pas
d'inscription au casier judiciaire et
qu'ils ne fassent pas l'objet de
poursuites judiciaires diverses marie
ensuite il a été employé comme je lisais
194 jours jusqu'en 2015 bon ya pas eu de
remontée négative de 2015 à 2017 il
était toujours sous statut et sert même
s'il n'était pas convoqué et donc on a
pas eu d'information qui l'aurait l'est
ce qui aurait laissé à penser qu'il y
avait un problème judiciaire ou qui
qu'il ait eu qu'il a eu un comportement
comportement anormal donc là dessus
au moment où il change de statut fin
il n'est pas utile de refaire je dirais
ce travail de criblage comme on dit
parce qu'il a déjà été fait et qu'on est
dans la continuité
il change de statut mais globalement
c'est toujours le même globalement on va
pas refaire leur enquête
on est aussi dans une logique de
simplification administrative et dans le
cadre de ce de ce recrutement il n'est
pas apparu réglementairement d'alors que
on avait déjà fait le travail il n'était
pas utile de le leur faire une deuxième
fois est ce que on a un réserviste qui
est avait le même grade au même âge à ce
stade
à ma connaissance non maintenant on
pourra regarder dans le détail en termes
de réservistes citoyens si on n'est pas
voilà mais j'ai pas fait le la totalité
du merci mon général et maintenant
madame friendly merci monsieur le
président général d'abord j'aimerais
vous exprimer très grand respect et la
reconnaissance la gendarmerie nationale
et tout particulièrement les missions
exercées notamment dans nos territoires
ruraux votre écoute et votre
disponibilité en général ma question
rejoint un petit peu celle de monsieur
alain marc et celle qui a été posée par
le président philippe bas vous avez dit
que lorsque vous avez recruté monsieur
benalla ce qui a beaucoup pesé c'est en
fait ces compétences opérationnelles
je me pose la question d'une enquête de
moralité qui aurait peut-être dû
intervenir à nouveau dans un deuxième
temps ma question est la suivante à
aucun moment parce que vous nous avez
parlé des sharks eux qu'ils étaient
chargés de la protection de nombreuses
personnalités que ça avait pesé dans le
recrutement
est ce que à aucun moment il n'a été
porté à votre connaissance
il semblerait qu'il ait eu monsieur
benalla des comportements non
recommandables lorsqu'il était en charge
d'une protection d'une personnalité gicl
merci chers collègues en général merci
madame la sénatrice pour cette question
merci pour votre soutien
mais non moi je n'ai eu aucune remontée
d'un comportement inadapté de quelle que
nature que ce soit je le disais
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure sur l'accident
qui a été évoquée à la faveur d'une
mission profit de monsieur montebourg
que j'ai découvert dans la presse je
n'ai eu au moment où on l'a intégré dans
la réserve spécialistes aucune remontée
négative d'aucune sorte sur le
comportement ou l'action monsieur
alexandre benalla générale madame le
reporter vous poser une question
merci monsieur le président oui général
à ce stade de notre audition il ya un
certain nombre d'éléments qui pose
question alors on a bien saisi pour quel
motif vous avez donné ce grade à
monsieur b dallas pour qu'ils soient en
réalité à la hauteur de ses
interlocuteurs dans cette mission qui
n'a jamais été mise en oeuvre parce
qu'ils en appellent la disponibilité en
revanche avec quelques questions qui
restent lorsque vous nous indiquez que
vous avez été motivés donc par cette
expérience en réalité dont il vous a
fait part par ses compétences et ses
diplômes dont il vous a fait part
également puisqu'en 2009 par définition
regard de sa date de naissance
il ne pouvait pas les avoir donc c'était
purement déclaratif la question sous
jacente mais en réalité que tout le
monde se pose donc je crois que notre
commission doit la poser aussi c'est un
moment ou un autre
avez vous eu un contact avec l'elysée
sur ce dossier et un moment ou un autre
vous êtes vous vous même influencé par
le fait que cette demande arrivait de
quelqu'un qui se prévalait de ses
fonctions à l'elysée en général merci
pour cette question
le rapporteur a le mérite d'être tirées
et la vérité direct et ça donne
l'occasion de le dire non à aucun moment
en aucune circonstance personne ne m'a
contacté je n'ai contacté personnalisés
et c'est très clair c'est une décision
personnelle que j'assume parce que ça
fait suite comme je lisais à les
discussions que j'ai eues avec avec
l'intéressé merci beaucoup mon général
de cette précision monsieur fisher oui
merci monsieur le président mon général
simplement ça va je crois qu'il ya un
parallèle un petit peu dans le parcours
de monsieur kraz par rapport au parcours
de monsieur benalla l'un est chef
d'escadron je ne sais pas quel
grade ça correspond et l'autre devient
lieutenant colonel alors qu'il
semblerait que me suis écrasé une
intériorité beaucoup plus importante que
monsieur benalla est ce qu'il ya une
raison au fait que la haye titre
d'expert quel expert l'autre pas enfin
et puis l'autre question c'est que
j'aimerais ça parce que j'ai posé la
question hier j'ai pas une réponse très
précise
est ce que quand on est lieutenant
colonel de réserve on a aussi tous les
attributs c'est-à-dire l'uniforme les
grades equiterra et donc pour accéder
dans les lieux où exercer un
couronnement quelque part en général
merci pour cette question du sénateur
alors les les
c'est ce que j'essaie d'expliquer par
mon propos liminaire les deux personnes
sont dans un statut différent le grade
du chef d'escadron donc qui correspond
au grade de commandant vincent kral est
un grade qui a obtenu à la faveur du
lancement d'une progression hiérarchique
dans le cas de la réserve opérationnelle
de sécurité publique classique et grades
qu'ils conservent globalement il part
demain il revient après demain il sera
toujours chef d'escadron on le réintègre
au même grade et il est employé dans ses
fonctions d'encadrement il a encadré
d'ailleurs des préparations militaires
gendarmerie il a fait plus de 400 jours
de réserve depuis 2000 donc c'est
quelqu'un qui est reconnue en plus comme
étant un bon professionnel je dirais
dans le domaine de la rive le grade de
monsieur alexandre vialatte n'a rien à
boire
ce n'est pas un grade dans le cadre je
dirais d'un réseau opérationnel de
sécurité publique cette ingrate qui
correspond à sa mission qui n'en portent
ni prérogatives de commandement rooney
prérogatives de puissance publique ne
port d'insignes comme vous le soulignez
on est dans une logique de spécialistes
il avait vocation il ne l'a pas fait
pour des raisons pratiques on n'a pas pu
le convoquer mais il n'a pas vocation à
commander les gens au même titre
d'ailleurs que la réserve citoyenne n'a
pas vocation pour ce qui nous concerne a
porté la tenue ce qui est pas le cas par
an
pour nos amis de la marine les
réservistes citoyens peuvent porter
l'uniforme et en ce qui concerne l'armée
nationale l'uniforme il est porté par
des réservistes opérationnels qui ont
des missions de sécurité publique
générale au quotidien et donc les
statuts vraiment de monsieur vincent
kraz monsieur alexandre nerfs sont
totalement différents monsieur leroy oui
monsieur le président merci mon général
vous parlez effectivement beaucoup de
spécialités et c'est vrai que les
gendarmes sont spécialisés dans la
sécurité et notamment dans la protection
des autorités puisque quand on sait la
formation la durée de la formation les
qualités et les capacités du j espère qu
homme du gign dans le cadre votre avis
m'intéresse pensez vous que l'apport de
personnes non alignés sur la même
fréquence que les pros de la sécurité
rapprochée pourrait constituer un danger
ou un handicap pour l'autorité protéger
en général je suis pas sûr d'avoir bien
compris la question
moi je considère que les gens notamment
s'agissant du président mais aussi
l'ensemble des autorités ministérielles
protégé par les personnels du jeu et
espère pour le président du sdlp pour
les autorités de premier niveau
ces protections sont faites par des
gendarmes ou des policiers
ces agissements des autorités et à ma
connaissance il n'y a pas de l'immixtion
quelle que nature que ce soit enfin j'ai
pas connaissance de ça en même temps
c'est pas mon domaine de compétence donc
je suis mal placé pour vous réponds mais
très clairement
moi je constate que les gendarmes
j'espère en tout cas devons pas faire
remonter difficultés et que globalement
ils font leur métier au quotidien avec
leurs camarades la police nationale
alors monsieur d'europe rapidement oui
très rapidement autrement dit
effectivement la protection rapprochée
de benalla du président ne pouvait-il
pas gêner effectivement l'action du gspr
qui sont des pros de la garde rapprochée
l'appréciation technique alors moi je
suis bien incapable pardon de répondre à
cette question d'abord parce que je suis
pas moi-même spécialistes en matière de
protection des personnes je n'ai jamais
tenu aucune fonction ni aucune formation
dans le domaine de la protection des
personnes donc là moi je sais pas
comment sont organisées le dispositif au
sein d y est c'est pas dans mon domaine
de compétence et je suis à ce stade
incompétent pour répondre à la question
il semble prêt à vous entendre et que
son rôle soit strictement limitée à
l'organisation des déplacements nous a
dit qu'ils participaient jusqu'à présent
l'organisation des déplacements publics
et qui l'organisait lui même les
déplacements privés
mais par ailleurs il est présentée
d'abord comme quelqu'un qui se préoccupe
des questions de sécurité puisque il a
été même intégré à la réserve
opérationnelle spécialisés de la
gendarmerie en raison en raison de son
expertise sur la protection des hautes
personnalités
puisque nous a dit le général du rpt et
ensuite il a tous les attributs d'un
policier le port d'armes notamment un
peu curieux pour quelqu'un on a tous
connu des chefs de câbles d'énergie de
mission faisaient simplement de
l'organisation il n'était jamais armées
aient jamais d'abord formé en question
de sécurité par ailleurs vous nous dites
qu'il se présentait comme chef adjoint
de cabinet mais qu'ils ne l'étaient pas
et donc ça interpelle un peu n'est pas
le premier à nous le dire le ministre
lui-même nous a dit qu'il s'était
autoproclamé hadj en chef de cabinet
donc est-ce que ça ça ne m'inquiète pas
quand même parfois lorsque dans la haute
administration dans des cabinets les
gens se prévalent d'une qualité qui
n'est pas la leur et quand on est
adjoint de chef de cabinet on peut
facilement se substituer au chef de
cabinet quand on est plus spécialisée
que son chef de cabinet sur les
questions de sécurité prendre la main
sur sur l'ailé les questions de sécurité
doc on a du mal à croire dans ces
conditions que vraiment il ne
s'intéressait pas aux questions de
sécurité par ailleurs on nous a dit qu
en tout cas qui n'était jamais armées
lors des déplacements publics
en revanche quid des déplacements privés
est-ce qu'il est armé pour est ce qu'il
aurait pu assurer les missions de
protection d'effacement privée et est ce
qu il arrive que le j'espère lâche le
président de la république au moment des
placements privés ou est-ce que le gspr
surveille la veille à la sécurité du
président de la république 24 heures sur
24 365 jours par an
il ya eu un moment de un moment où il
n'y aurait plus que monsieur ben ali et
enfin dernière question sur la réforme
ont annoncé une réforme du j'espère avec
la fusion j'espère commandement
militaire est ce que vous avez eu vent
de ces idées et est ce que dans cette
hypothèse la sécurité du président
échapperait aux services de protection
et serait totalement autonome
tu rappelles que nous a été expliqué
tout à l'heure et on donne un sens au
mot qui n'ont peut-être pas par
eux-mêmes qu'il fallait distinguer un
chef adjoint du cabinet d'un adjoint au
chef de cabinet et monsieur si j'ai bien
compris monsieur benallal jamais été
chef adjoint du cabinet il a été l'un
des deux adjoints du chef de cabinet ce
qui semble-t-il est une distinction
importante dans cette hiérarchie par
administrative mais nous comprenons que
adjoint c'est moins important adjoint au
chef c'est moins important que chef
adjoint c'est ce que j'ai compris faut
visiter voilà et ça permet de mieux
comprendre la localisation exacte
monsieur benalla dans la hiérarchie de
ce que j'ai entendu qualifié pour la
première fois de ma vie de chez fleury
de cabinet j'ai vécu en afrique les
chefferies j'ai connu je ne savais pas
qu à l'elysée il y avait aussi une
chefferie
voilà alors le alors et monsieur
l'inspecteur général pour répondre à
notre collègue est ce que vous me
permettez de fer l'ordre inversé
monsieur c'est la mesure de répondre à
votre dernière question sur la réflexion
sur la réflexion qui est en cour à
l'elysée
je je je vous répondrai tout simplement
ce qu'a répondu le ministre il faut que
le lien avec le ministère de l'intérieur
subsiste j'ai pas d'autres commentaires
et ce sont les paroles au ministre que
je reprends mon compte
premier élément et je n'ai pas d'autres
éléments vous fournir sur 7 sur cette
réflexion
deuxième élément le ministère dont je
dépends a émis un avis négatif sur la
demande de port d'armes de monsieur
benalla
je reste à ma place je reste à ma place
dois je vous dire que j'étais
extrêmement défavorable au fait qu'une
personne non non policier jeudi un
fonctionnaire une personne privée puisse
être armés alors qu'un dispositif de
protection constitué de professionnels
aguerris puisse être présent dans la
méthodologie d'action s'il y en avait un
événement venait tation venir c'était
incompatible je l'avais fait savoir cela
a été repris en plus d'un certain nombre
d'arguments
moi je n'ai voilà je j'ai dit d'entrée
quand la question était posée une totale
réticence est une autre suivi par l'ons
ministre du ministère de l'intérieur je
n'ai pas d'autres commentaires à faire
voilà donc je reste dans le cadre de mes
compétences il y avait une troisième
question excusez moi monsieur le cncr
veille à la sécurité du président 24
heures sur 24 365 jours par an oui oui
monsieur sénateurs mais je pense que le
chef du j'espère qui est au quotidien
dans cette mission sera plus apte à vous
répondre que je ne peux l'être avec des
imprécisions qui ne serait pas l'auteur
de cette haute assemblée
voilà pour les temps forts de ces
auditions de la commission d' enquête
qui s'est constitué à la suite de la
ferme et nahla au mois de juillet des
auditions qui se sont tenues vous l'avez
vu dans le calme et qui ont permis de
mettre en lumière un certain nombre de
contradictions dans les témoignages
notamment autour de la retenue sur
salaire qui aurait eu lieu sur la
rémunération d'alexandre benalla
finalement on a découvert qu'il n'y en
avait pas eu également autour de la
fiche de poste la fonction d'alexandre
benalla noter d'ailleurs que philippe
bas le président de la commission des
lois a affirmé avoir demandé cette fiche
de poste à l'elysée et que pour
l'instant cela lui a été refusé
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
mercredi matin ne manquez pas la reprise
des travaux sur la sphère benalla de la
commission denquête avec l'audition de
trois personnalités proches de l'enquète
françois-xavier lauch chef de cabinet d'
emmanuel macron également le général
eric bio-farina commandant militaire de
la présidence de la république
et enfin maxence creusa commissaire de
police à la direction de l'ordre public
et de la circulation de la préfecture de
police de paris
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]